so we were gonna lead with the story
about j6 that woman who got caught lying
again it's funny because you have
conservative papers that hate trump and
you have democrats and they're all like
this is the bombshell testimony and then
a bunch of people come out they're like
yeah i will swear under oath she's lying
but they believe it anyway
and then we thought you know what it's
just so boring can we make fun of
ocasio-cortez instead because colbert
asked her to run for president or ask if
she was gonna run for president and she
didn't say no and she was like yeah well
you know and then she also it's it's
really amazing because
you know uh please someone what someone
help this country aoc goes on on prime
time television to millions of people
and she strung a bunch of words about
the civil war together that made
literally no sense and everyone's
clapping for it and i'm just like
she does
it's amazing it's she made comments
about abraham lincoln the supreme court
why joe biden should take certain action
and it's like she just made it all up
it's absolutely amazing her her timeline
is wrong her history is wrong the
actions taken were wrong and i'm sitting
there watching and colbert's like you
should be president and i'm like oh look
at that that's actually pretty chad you
know just go on television in front of a
bunch of people who can fact check you
and start making stuff up like yeah i
know he should do this because that's
what abe lincoln did and you're like do
you have a source like i made it up yeah
no i mean that happened six years she's
like abraham lincoln
you know dred scott was issued so
abraham lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation and it's like aoc that was
six years before she said six years she
said the confederates packed the supreme
court or she said the confederates got
their people into the supreme court it's
like what are you talking about you know
what okay so so we it's gonna be fun
roasting all that but there's some other
funny news too in iowa
but after roe v wade's repeal
republicans gained in the polls
so they can come out and i'll tell you
this too the democrats were funding
trump supporting candidates thinking was
going to help them and then in colorado
the moderate won so they wasted all of
that money and just propped up and
expanded trump's message these people
are not smart people and aoc she really
really does prove it every single day so
we're going to talk about that plus
we'll talk about what's going on with
january 6 but my friends before we get
started head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to pick up your
keto elevate from biotrust this is
c8 uh medium chain triglycerides if
you're doing the keto diet or trying to
cut back on sugar eat right and feel
well.com has exactly what you need it's
outrusts
mctc8c8 mct powder you'll get 51 off and
biotrust will also give you a 60 day
money back guarantee they provide you
with only ca to the most ketogenic mct
that means it provides support for
energy levels healthy appetite
management mental clarity and focus
athletic performance
five grams of the highly sought after
mctc8 per scoop keto elevates personally
they do write this here but it is my
favorite i mentioned this last time we
actually had someone brought in some
other uh mct supplements i tried it
actually didn't really like it i really
do like the the biotrust stuff and as an
aside too
since i started cutting out the sugar
and using more of this stuff frequently
in my diet i've lost 30 pounds no joke
watch the videos from pre november watch
now i lost a lot of weight for every
order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year you'll
get free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order you know what i actually want to
drive this point home
like i didn't intend on using this stuff
to lose a bunch of weight but i legit
lost 30 pounds so
no joke i cut out the sugars i was
reading this stuff and i was like i
should just stop eating sugar and then
one day i did and then within a couple
months i lost a ton of weight and then
gradually started losing a bunch more so
go to eatrightandfeelwell.com it's more
than just buying keto elevate i i cut
out the breads the grains the sugars and
i've really really cut down on the
sugars and this stuff really does help
because i'm trying to find ways to get
the energy back i've been putting in my
coffee along with a lot of cream and
having a lot of a much more higher fat
high protein diet so check it out don't
forget head over to timcast.com and
become a member to help support our work
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 pm the uncensored
after hours show where we swear a lot
and you don't want your kids listening
to that one but it is a whole lot of fun
and it's often very funny you'll also be
supporting our journalists and our
infrastructure we use rumble so we can
help build an ecosystem that is more
resilient to censorship for everybody so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and joining us today
to discuss all of this we got royce
white
thanks for having me who are you what do
you do
well i guess the most important thing
i'm doing right now is running for
united states congress against ilhan
omar well in minnesota's fifth
congressional district and we're in the
the dead heat of that campaign i got a
primary august 9th
against a a rhino uniparty globalist
uh who who said that abortion was red
meat politics for the base at our
convention wow and when roe v wade
passed she she celebrated it because i
mean you don't have to keep a count of
the things you said yesterday when it
got overturned yeah
she acted like she was on on board so
yeah running for congress also playing
in the big three
um our season started two weeks ago and
and i got that going on as well and
still trying to mix martial arts every
day in preparation for whenever the
election is over to to try and fight
again right amen thanks for hanging out
we also got shim sham uh yeah before i
uh introduce myself i just wanted to
make a comment here you mentioned the
republicans becoming more popular uh
after banning abortion
there's this talking point we kept
hearing about roe v wade and if it's
overturned people will turn against
republicans it'll hurt them in the polls
like yeah you know what's going to make
republicans really unpopular if they
accomplish something for once ever that
would be so bad for them doing what the
republicans ask the politicians to do is
is bad for 50
years they finally did the thing finally
accomplished it looks it's a bad look i
know um i am sheamus coughlin i run a
youtube channel called freedom tunes and
this unfortunately is going to be my
last show for a while so they've made me
a cake which i very much appreciate liz
decorated this what's that
um because for just five bucks a month
you can become a member
freedomtunes.com so i know that i'm
going to be leaving for the show for a
while here folks but you can still get
your dose of sheamus go to
freedomtunes.com become a member you'll
get an extra cartoon each week you'll be
helping us get independent from youtube
i love you all and i think this is going
to be a great show
it says we'll miss you on the cake and
it says we'll miss you i know you won't
but we're not we we're not about fake
news on this show
but hold on it says will miss you it's
not necessarily it
that's not indicative of a consensus
right like at least at least two people
here will miss oh that's true at least
two yeah at least two at least two all
right fair point yeah technically
correct happy birthday sheamus but not
morally accurate thank you
what's up everybody ian crossland up in
the house uh nothing to shout out yet so
let's just get going let's move it along
i'm excited we always have a great time
with royce i am the one who did the
lettering on that cake it is not my
finest work but i did it in about 10
minutes i think i should have said irish
you already that was brett's idea i know
i was like how why were you not here 10
minutes earlier but oh well we will miss
sheamus all right everybody let's jump
into this first story we got it from the
huffington post you know how much we
love them post alexandria ocasio-cortez
has pithy reply when asked if she'll run
for president the popular progressive
house member had just watched cassidy
hutchinson's testimony at the january 6
hearing when colbert popped the question
that's right they're getting married
everybody
aoc i'm kidding so he asks her he's like
this is really really funny because he
roasted joe biden at the same time so
respect for that
uh
they don't actually oh they don't
actually show what he said about colbert
that's funny he said no matter how many
times people ask joe biden if he's gonna
run for reelection and he says yes they
ignore what he says and then ask other
people to run
so the new york times actually ran this
article check this out biden irked by
democrats who won't take yes for an
answer on 2024. yo it's not about taking
yes for an answer it's about how even if
you say yes they're like dude's brain
doesn't work so there they don't think
he's gonna run anyway
so here's the best part
colbert is like i know someone who's
gonna turn 35 and uh right before the
election ha ha could it be you and then
she said listen we need to keep we need
to focus on keeping democracy for
anybody to be president the next couple
of years she replied my central focus is
helping the people of this country right
now so it's possible i don't know about
that
well i don't think she's actually going
to run but the fact that on primetime tv
stephen colbert is asking her if she
will i think what we're seeing you had
cnn say hillary it's her time now did
you see that article from chris saliza
then everyone made fun of her this is
hilarious one of her her former campaign
strategist came out and said her polling
is actually her numbers our ratings are
worse than trump's
so he's like no no no no no hillary no
she's not coming back i think the
democrats in the estate in the corporate
press they're desperate to try and find
someone
i think the goal of asking aoc is so
that they drop the stone in the water to
see where the ripples go they make the
statement and now they want to see how
the press handles it and what the
reaction from the public is yes they
never said she's going to run but what
happens if all of a sudden people start
saying yeah aoc should run and there's
big fervor and fire under it then
they'll be like oh oh yeah okay so
they're testing the waters trying to see
who they can get and i got to be honest
when i heard that they asked that
colbert asked if she'd run
i'm like
out of all the democrats that are
available she'd beat them all save
michelle obama maybe
but gavin knew some aoc would do better
well i think there's there's an
important point here so if the democrats
know anything that they're starting to
realize that they don't have that much
of a shot in 2024 if trends continue
there's not much hope for their party
right now and so it could be possible
that what they would plan on doing is
putting up some throwaway candidate in
2024 whose anti-establishment and
actually relatively popular with their
base so that next time an election comes
along when a democrat actually does
stand a chance of winning they can go we
tried this anti-establishment person the
people weren't interested they lost
we're not going to run them or they can
use as an opportunity to raise aoc's
profile
right now she's just a popular house
member she's not a senator she's not
that big a presidential campaign run
where they expect to lose can can push
her up to a very prominent public space
at the national level am i in this
conversation already absolutely yeah
jump in okay good
uh we got to debunk this right now i
can't i can't stand it
this whole facade that aoc is
anti-establishment
fair enough fair enough it's a complete
scam they want a runner as
anti-establishment exactly i want to say
that exactly the ploy that they're
running is that
when you say you're socialist then
you're anti-corporate
but when you plan to expand socialism to
the global scale it's the ultimate form
of corporatism yeah i would agree and
also there's nothing aoc believes that
our public education system has not been
set up to brainwash children into
believing so i know i totally agree i
mean she eats out of the palm of the
establishment but she's viewed as an
outsider but if they don't and i wanted
to say if they
if they don't win in 2024 it's over
because the young
america first populous movement that's
on the rise
is going to go in and crush
the old narrative that allowed an aoc to
pose as anti-corporate and it's all
mostly predicated on
one the story of blacks historically in
the country that's kind of the lynchpin
of grievance politics and
anti-establishment but also the young
people who are indoctrinated at schools
and if the conservatives win in the
midterms and 2024
we got to go back and take those schools
i think we're headed towards a um
there's a strong possibility of hyper
racialization happening in the next
several years there was a viral thread
where this uh this dude said
you know uh there are young white men in
school being told that they're the
oppressors then they see that most
people in college are female then they
see that
like you know when they apply for a job
they're like we're not hiring any white
men and so this is a big thread where
they explained that you know maybe it
applies to older white men because when
those older white men were younger they
were the majority and they controlled a
lot of the space but now that it's
inverted younger white men are growing
up being told that they're the evil
oppressors but they're getting held back
and they're getting restrained so
they're getting angry and they're
forming racial identitarian groups or
they're starting to coalesce around race
so the left
in pushing this stuff i think is hyper
racializing everything 100 100 what
they're banking on is that white people
are always going to self-flagellate
every single time a discussion on racial
issues comes up because that's sort of
been the status quo but ultimately at
some point white guilt runs out
so it's it's generational it's
generational memory
uh what people don't understand when it
comes to politics they talk about like
the pay gap right yeah but for which
demographic the pay gap exists for sure
among boomers the pay gap exists among
millennials but it's inverted millennial
women make more money than millennial
men millennial women are more likely to
graduate college than millennial men yet
they keep pushing a narrative as if it's
the younger generation suffering what
the older generation went through and
that's going to cause a serious problem
because in these stories whether it's
about uh leftist racial unitarianism
creating more white
identitarianism or
social issues that
were relevant 50 years ago not being
relevant today and then punishing young
people today based on the grievances of
the past you are going to raise a
generation with an inverted
system which causes oppression which
causes anger and animosity the only
difference is right now they're telling
the young majority white males that
they're evil and oppressors and then
restricting them but these young young
men don't know anything about the civil
rights movement they didn't experience
that they weren't part of it they only
think about slavery jim crow they
weren't a part of it they don't think
about the klan they don't they they're
not alive during a time of the clan and
they weren't a part of it
but they're still the majority so what
happens when you when you raise a the
majority and and tell them that they're
evil oppressors and you take from them
you make it harder for them
yo they're going to come out in force
they're going to vote in force and then
it's really going to flip pendulum is
going to swing hard in the other
direction
a bunch of kids that believe they're
evil oppressors grow up to become evil
oppressors
that's not what i'm saying well that's
gonna happen i'm saying that
it's possible a lot of people do
it's that this this you know 17 year old
white kid is like there's you said
there's a pay gap why do all the women
make more money you said you said that
men are privileged how come i can't get
a job you say that men are how come the
women are the ones who are graduating
from college right how is it me because
they do not live in the generations past
this this thing where people are telling
us one thing but it's not right like
that the economy is doing great when you
have like the the speaker
it's driving people crazy it's driving
me crazy it's got to be driving young
people crazy because they don't have the
context i have at least the outlet i
have for the most part not that all of
them don't but i mean it's got to be
driving people insane
that's dangerous my my concern about the
entire race conversation that i've been
thinking about more recently is
the concept of white itself mm-hmm
i don't like it i totally agree what do
you mean by that well
i'm irish
what i mean is it's true there's a bit
of a double cross and triple cross when
it comes to saying who's white
i mean barack obama was white
what i mean is
you know
in in europe let's say for example is
white sorry nobody nobody calls
themselves white you're from spain
you're from romania you're from
uh italy you're from
the uk you're irish whatever the case
may be
in america we've kind of been the
driving force of creating a a
you know unified
white identity that's an amalgamation of
a bunch of european clans that used to
oppress and kill each other and that
framework of history gets completely
lost on young people still do for sure
but
but that exactly yeah well the russians
aren't even considered white and modern
they're they're slavs but yeah yeah
slavics are people of color apparently
they are people covered yeah like our
friend luke yeah yeah so but that but it
just it it just shows you that the
history uh is is something that's lost
on on many people and it's premise
point about this but just uh as you
mentioned your problem with the concept
of white i agree luke rudkowski has
blonde hair and blue eyes yeah but he's
slavic so they say he's a person of
color and i'm just like all right you
lost me dude yeah no it's completely
absurd i've said this before the idea of
just like one wholesale white identity
erases the different ethnic groups that
actually fall under that umbrella and
it's interesting how that definition has
changed over time historically in this
country it was basically a label that
was used to exclude catholics it was all
of the people who had white skin but
were from catholic cultures who were
considered non-white so the irish the
polish the italians and now today irish
people are considered white but irish
people weren't considered white until
being white meant you had to apologize
for being white all the time well so
this is this is actually the left's
argument that's what it is their
argument is that white changes
that italian people weren't considered
white therefore white whiteness today
doesn't really mean the color of your
skin it means like your idea is your
social structure right well you know the
washington post said that i'm far-right
white nationalist now they're going to
start calling black people
cheers they're going to start calling
black people who are america first larry
elder yeah you're white
clarence thomas it's like it's like
dave chappelle's skit has come to life
clayton was it clayton bixby big speed
yeah yeah i can't you know dave you're a
prophet how is this how is this real
life it's almost like he manifested it
he made the skit thinking like this i'll
make something so crazy it'll never work
you know the fascinating thing about
that clayton bigsby segment was it
showed that it was about culture and
ideas more than race that in his bit the
point being made was that the white
supremacists were like he's such a good
speaker and his ideas are so beneficial
to us we gotta we gotta keep him around
and then there was the scene where he
sees he hears the rap music and it's
three white guys and then he calls him a
racial slur and they liked it because
they were trying to people right they're
like cool
yeah like the the point was interesting
is that it was about culture not about
race
and i think that that actually is still
true today
but you know i agree with you but they
wanna they wanna have it both ways right
so the left wants to talk about this
idea of a white identity and um they'll
claim that whiteness changes over time
and it's an arbitrary construct but then
they'll turn around and go you have
white skin you are objectively white
therefore i don't have to listen to your
opinion dave chappelle was also
brilliant in that and when he said he
made the joke that people in the lgbtq
like to claim that they're minorities
until it was time to be white right
like when he made the skit about the
cops being called and yeah nobody nobody
who's black and trans says oh well my
name is clifford because when the cop
shows up they don't care who which one
of you is clifford they you know if you
have blacks basically he was saying that
black skin is an immutable quality
and gender identity is not immutable
yeah well so this is something i i used
to bring this up because one argument
that was always made around 10 years ago
is that like oh you know the um question
of homosexuality and homosexual unions
and lgbtq rights is like the racial
struggle of our day it's the civil
rights struggle and that's completely
absurd i mean first of all like there's
no in the closet if you're black right
right like you're just black everywhere
it's it's completely different it's
completely different but they want
because it's understood that it's a
powerful rhetorical tool because
americans care a whole lot about race if
you want people to be sympathetic to a
group of people you say look what's
happening to them is just like what
happened black people historically
they mentioned that this is like the
civil rights fight of our day they say
things like you know sheamus you would
have been on the side of jim crow and
slavers and it's like no catholics were
not yeah and it's not just that it's
that like we're effectively dissidents
in the to the establishment we are
opposing the established order you guys
are in favor of what walmart wants right
but it's not the civil rights fight of
our day because none of it makes sense
like when larry elder comes out and he
says here's what i think we can do for
black families and they go you're a
white supremacist i'm like bro you're a
white person calling a black man a white
supremacist because you don't like his
politics it's ridiculous you're not
fighting for civil rights you're just an
egotist who doesn't like the fact that
your your cudgel racism doesn't work or
makes sense the same things with candace
owens
black white supremacists no
neither they're neither that's that's
insane they're just people with ideas
you don't like well the people who they
think are white supremacists aren't in
white supremacists let alone the black
people being white supremacists but the
other the other interesting historical
piece of this that i think paints this
cultural appropriation that the lgbtq
movement is doing
goes all the way back to the black
panthers and fred hampton
fred hampton was the original creator
and founder of the rainbow coalition
and it wasn't until nine years after he
died that the artist from california
took the rainbow icon and used it for
the lgbtq and what most people don't
talk about when they talk panthers or
fred hampton or the rainbow coalition
is that the white organization that was
a part of the three organizations that
that made up the rainbow coalition
were the young patriots and guess what
their icon was the confederate flag
wow they were southerners
let me ask you let me ask you something
so they decided to change the i remember
they changed the pride flag and they
added a black and brown stripe no clue
what it means don't ask me it's it's for
black and brown people no it's not
that's what they said yeah yeah but i'm
just i'm just like is it if this flag is
for lesbian gay bisexual and trans
is it did they add did they add another
b to it for black
so it's lgbtqbb why are black and brown
people in the lgbt flag like what's the
incineration
right i don't understand this stuff
right now well it's also i've said this
before on the show but it's the design
is so stupid because for like the
different sexual identities they want
these different colors of the rainbow to
represent something abstract and it's
like what is the brown for it's like
brown people it was the black or black
people it's like wait
but like why didn't they get creative
colors why did everyone else get they
added a white triangle to it did they
really yeah they did yeah learning that
they're right for white people rainbows
from the rainbow coalition which was a
multicultural thing makes a lot more
sense well the rainbow was well the
rainbow coalition was initially
um
fred hampton although the black panthers
had this marxist-leninist
uh philosophical background
uh fred hampton was kind of an anomaly
in chicago and he had his own
you know
version of the black panthers you could
say and and that was the rainbow
coalition in which he kind of reoriented
the black panthers focus on the working
class and he said that despite the
racial issues that do exist in america
there is a greater
predation happening on the working class
economically that was the whole motif of
the rainbow coalition was the working
the unity of working class whites blacks
and and latinos so each color and the
original pride flag like represented
some idea yeah and i think they actually
had magic in there and then they were
like we should yeah we should get rid of
the magic from this flag it doesn't make
sense and then um i don't understand the
one thing i understand is how like is
there a committee that decides when the
flag should be changed because one day
people were just like hey we added black
and brown and then everyone started
making these these flags with a black
and brown stripe then they were like
okay actually we're going to put the
trans triangle in the side
and we're going to put the black and
brown in the triangle instead and then
someone was like we should put a yellow
triangle in there too and a purple
circle now all of a sudden those flags
are flying everywhere but like who
decided that would be the flag like you
know what i mean it's like did you start
making it what is it going to look like
in two years
well the joke is that the the the the
trans triangle is pushing the rainbow
out
because it's gradually taking up more
and more space
all right i got to give a shout out look
we're we're going to keep the focus on
uh i guess the racial politics of the
day because we have more from colbert
and aoc and i'm sorry you know there's a
lot of important things we can talk
about but making fun of aoc is fun it's
fun and um look i i i i try not to be
overtly just like ha ha let's mock her
for the sake of mocking her yo she went
on stephen colbert's show to millions of
people
strung together a bunch of history words
that made no sense
with a straight face
and i'm just it's laughably absurd that
she would be asked if she would be
president after saying something so
nonsensical but you know sheamus pointed
out it's a chad move to go on tv and
just be like
yeah you know um abraham lincoln yeah he
was a capricorn and uh uh uh you know
winsted churchill they were cousins oh
wow that's crazy yeah separate and
you're it's like making like stephen
cole bears like will you be my president
wow i didn't know that yeah yeah yeah
joan of arc yeah yeah that's lincoln's
mom that's pretty cool for sure let me
play you this clip don't know john of
arc was noah's wife haven't you seen
those right yeah yeah
let me play this clip for you cause it's
gonna make you laugh
so colbert basically answers a ton of
questions for aoc on our behalf and then
she says this what action would you like
to see the congress take well i think uh
history really informs the law you turn
this up does it inform you let me start
our
proportion can you up in the turn to the
people and big in the volume
well i think uh history really informs a
lot and it gives us lessons here because
this is not the first time that this has
happened in the 1800s the supreme court
was taken over
by the confederate south and was
starting to
rule in ways that limited abraham
lincoln for example in in the dred scott
ruling they ruled that black americans
are not and can never be full citizens
united states and what did abraham
lincoln do he signed the emancipation
proclamation
i thought she was gonna say he packed
the court
uh franklin delano roosevelt yo she just
strung a bunch of words together all
right let me break it down for you
everybody
the supreme court was not taken over by
the confederacy because the confederacy
was not a part of the union they did not
rule in ways that impeded abraham
lincoln because abraham lincoln became
president after secession dred scott was
one thing she got right a ruling that
said citizenship was not for descendants
for people of african descent but dred
scott happened four years before abraham
lincoln became president and abraham
lincoln did not issue the emancipation
proclamation in response to dred scott
the emancipation proclamation was issued
two years after he became president six
years after dred scott and has nothing
to do with citizenship at all it was the
14th amendment that came about after the
civil war that answered the question of
citizenship yo aoc went on colbert and
just said a bunch of civil war-era words
at the same time with confidence
i gotta admit sheamus you're right it's
chad mega chad she's like when abraham
lincoln first signed roe v wade into law
it was to free women from slavery oh my
god because the confederates had invaded
the supreme court and abraham lincoln
had no choice but to build an ark and
take two of each animal
yeah what i think she meant was
one of these things
before the civil war the south had
people that were becoming supreme court
justices and they were like leaning
towards the southern states their
beliefs and then when she said but then
and then they challenged abraham lincoln
what she meant was they challenged the
ideas that abraham lincoln came to
embody later
uh but she just messed it all up right i
mean if that's what she meant which is i
the only thing i can imagine she meant
you can she's just wrong you can imagine
anything you want what she said was a
string of 1860s related words
that didn't actually fit together and i
mean that was written by ace 60's that
was written by ai she wrote
she wrote roe v wade civil war and then
it struck that together but but i'm i'm
so impressed with the way she delivered
it with the utmost confidence yes yeah
that's pretty chad and she started off
with history in in in forms she's
letting everyone know i know that's kind
of forms and it gives a bunch of like
strange history i just that right i was
watching this and i was just like i'm
like the confederacy hadn't had invaded
the supreme court where impeding lincoln
i was like how are they impeding lincoln
he wasn't even president even if her
point was that southern
southern sympathetic justices were on
the court
they could not have in any way impeded
uh abraham lincoln because he wasn't
even president until after several
states had already seceded and said that
they were no longer part of the union
they and and there was a question before
he was even president as to whether
there would be military intervention to
stop session now granted fair point
abraham lincoln won the election and
then they were like all right that's it
we're out yeah
and then several months later several
states secede and then lincoln becomes
president he's like i don't recognize
any of this and things started to
escalate from there but had nothing to
do with the supreme court granted he did
try to go after a justice it's just when
i heard this and she was like dred scott
said that you know
black people weren't citizens so abraham
lincoln what did he do he issued the
emancipation proclamation i'm like those
two things are unrelated to each other
when judge dredd scott
decided
a judge
these these people offend me
these these are the black bourgeoisie
elite that are more interested in
diversity equity and inclusion full
politics than they are the american
people and later in this clip i think
she said something along the lines when
they ask her about running for president
i'm interested in helping the american
people uh no she's not i mean she's a
complete puppet she's a prop she's uh
she's an actress and she doesn't need to
know history because the entire
mainstream media apparatus
is is her backstop i'll tell you what
she is you've got you guys got to watch
the new beavers and butthead have has
anybody here seen the new beeps just a
clip
everybody's sharing the white privilege
clip but i got a minor minor spoiler for
you guys it's not it's not a story
spoiler um but it's kind of but i have
to say it
many of you may have seen it but there's
a point at which biebs and buddha for
some reason can't see
and so they're just like waving their
arms around with their eyes pointing in
the wrong directions both of them that's
aoc yeah it's not a puppet it's that she
like
was sitting in a room one day and
someone was like dude like dred scott
was like really bad because the us
government like these supreme court
people were like you're not a citizen
yeah the supreme court's illegitimate
they've been illegitimate she's like
yeah
and then someone's like but bro that
emancipation proclamation right and she
goes yeah and then she sits on the couch
and she goes well tread scrat and the
emancipation it's like some stoner dude
just said a bunch of random stuff it's
no one look if she was a puppet she'd
been given a cue card that would have
said something more coherent
you sit here right you take your seat
you explain dred scott
you explain civil war
i don't know i i tend to slightly
disagree i think the new
the new impetus towards societal control
psychological control is to see
if they can get people like aoc who are
conscious and know full well what
they're doing
uh to to vote for them still and i that
you know that's that's my interpretation
like and i don't know about her you're
right i don't know about aoc
but i know that some of these people
such as pelosi whether elizabeth warren
maybe some of the elders in the democrat
party or in the establishment
are fully aware of the lies that they're
telling
you're right you know i just you know
you know what i was realizing you ever
see those uh scammer emails from like a
nigerian prince yeah people always make
fun of them because the grammar is
really bad that's on purpose no for real
so
people assume if this the scammers are
doing a bad job because they're not
speaking proper english
the reason they do that is because they
don't want to waste time on smart people
aoc is saying dumb things here on
purpose to make sure that smart people
don't waste their time even talking
about what she's doing or engaging her
seriously but all of the dumb people
will fall for it right it's really good
so these these old people get an email
and it'll be like i'm a nigerian prince
send me a check for two thousand dollars
there's typos in it it makes no sense a
person of moderate intelligence says
this makes no sense exit out but if they
sent a really well thought out message a
smart person's going to be like i'm not
sending you any money it's the stupid
people they got to go after yeah so they
want to filter out the smart people and
slowly but surely make people dumber and
dumber so that the pool is bigger yeah
how many people do you think now are
like following this because colbert gets
about two million viewers
mostly not in the key demographic but
you know many how many people do you
think sat down today and they were like
well you know with dred scott um abraham
lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation so so biden should make a
declaration too and then
how many people do you think are going
to mindlessly repeat the gobbledygook
nonsense she just said way too many
way too many well i mean if only we had
some kind of disinformation board you
know
if only we had fact checkers
who actually cared about what our
politicians said i know can i wonder if
politifact mentioned any of this stuff
every now and again she will get fact
checked
keep talking i'm looking up yeah no no
i'm looking because i'm curious to see
what they'll have to say but
i mean obviously this is not some minor
blunder i don't think they even did it
detail's wrong look they i don't even
think they actually even fact checked
her hold on look at this the last thing
that was from may 9th thanks politifact
she just went on colbert and said a
whole bunch of nonsense that took me
five minutes to debunk not even five but
pretty fast
watches colbert yes two million people
oh wow two million people i still have
corrected i guess he does get views so
he gets a decent it's mostly not in the
key demo but he does get a decent key
demo viewership so first of all it is a
little bit unfair because i've been
reading a lot about the civil war so i
immediately knew these things made no
sense no it's not unfair that you know
facts that she's wrong about no no i'm
i'm saying like i immediately caught it
yeah maybe uh uh the average person
would not but journalists if they
actually cared i'm not talking about
journalism about regular people
it's it's it's unfair for me to be
critical of a regular person who didn't
know that and is repeating it to their
friends okay because they trust her but
journalists should be scrutinizing all
of the politicians the same they don't i
just also like i haven't read about the
civil war since middle school but the
claim that the south the confederacy had
infiltrated the supreme court like
that's literally not how the civil war
worked they they seceded before it was
yeah yeah exactly so it's not possible
well it's fair to say that there were
southern sympathetic justices yeah but
that's not the confederacy stopping abe
lincoln with the supreme court right she
she takes like this tiny morsel of what
what may be factual the the the
perception that the supreme court was
citing in ways that was more favorable
to the south in certain instances like
dred scott but then she turns it into
the confederacy had taken over the
supreme court and was impeding abraham
lincoln yeah with rulings like dred
scott so he had to issue the
emancipation proclamation is just
psychotic garbage doesn't make any sense
yeah
and i want to say i think
you know it's it's funny to me to watch
aoc talk
because she actually is the example of
the true systemic injustice done on the
american people
the real systemic injustice is to lower
the bar of intelligence of your leaders
and have you follow them
because you just don't know any better
to create a society of mindless bots
from a ver through a variety of ways and
then give you a puppet leader like aoc
that can in no way properly represent
you in governance or anything else for
that matter that's real systemic
injustice and she gets to run around
with the motif of systemic injustice as
the hallmark of her platform that's a
double cross and triple cross for the
ages it's like a popularity contest i
mean that's what voting is but do you
think it's that we shouldn't have voting
no we definitely should have voting but
i think what's been done to the school
systems in this country or education in
this country or or um
communities just in general
uh
was not done uh what was not organic
it was intentionally done it was
systematically designed
we we like a dumb populace and that's
why i call myself a populist politically
i'm i'm a i'm an america first christian
sovereignness actually you could say but
um i'm a populist
but but you know we do have a populace
right now that's grossly uh
undereducated and misinformed so it
makes it very hard for them to cast and
form votes in our political system
which is an egregious and egregious
level of moral hazard that comes from
institutions becoming corrupted and in
the west we do place a premium on the
individual
but culture does have an impact on the
individual and we have to understand
both things happen simultaneously but
when the when the establishment gets as
corrupt as it's become now you get 81
million people voting for a man who
shouldn't be allowed to drive a car
yeah i think corporations becoming
legally people
severely corrupted our capitalist
institution to the point where now
they're making corporations are making
political statements and that that you
can't sue them you can't destroy the
people sued them into oblivion the
owners they just declare it bankrupt
them
so nobody fact checked what she said
like
you're pissed about that well the point
i'm making here is
any conservative politician who even
says anything slightly wrong like ron
desantis was fact checked because
i can't remember exactly what he's
talking about but he said something
slightly imprecise and they're like
false false false we got him
aoc goes on prime time television at
millions of people strings together
random words and everyone's like i'm
okay with that yeah
you made a good point about aoc and i
think the word is almost controlled
opposition in a sense right she's
supposed to be the outsider candidate
but she really does
she does present everything that the
establishment would like for people to
believe i think a huge part of the
problem and i've got on my soapbox about
this a number of times on the show but
we have a culture which basically places
instant gratification above everything
else and even in really intimate
important ways so we've completely
saturated our society with pornography
and people eat gross fatty foods all the
time and basically the idea is you
shouldn't do things in line with their
purposes you should do things in line
with what brings you the most pleasure
and it trains people to constantly take
the path of least resistance and when
people take the path of least resistance
they're much easier to herd
it's much easier to get people to obey
you when they're gonna go along with
what's easiest right before i lose my
temper oh boy i need you to clarify what
you meant by gross and fatty foods okay
so basically and i don't mean to imply
that there's such a thing as anything
that's less healthy than something else
right everyone's healthy all the time
we're all equally healthy all foods are
equally beautiful that cake right
exactly that this cake is super healthy
and super good for me so do you mean
yeah gross fatty as one thing or do you
mean gross comma fatty gross kama fatty
well it's it's no right avocados are
fatty and they're good for you okay no
no okay i've been doing that you don't
actually get back fat can be very good
for you i'm talking like the kind of
stuff you get at mcdonald's and i'm
talking yeah it's fried it's sugary it's
salty and it's okay to have sugary foods
every now and again but if if your if
every meal you eat is this gross stuff
that's going to weigh you down and
destroy your brain and
it it again it trains you towards doing
something not in line with what makes
sense either for the occasion or for
what you're supposed to be eating um it
it trains you just to pursue pleasure
and so
when other people and and one of the
things that is pleasing to us is to fit
in with the crowd i want to so when
other people stand up and start
promoting bad ideas you're not going to
you're not going to listen to that so so
this is this idea i've heard uh i heard
from the left they talk about how
poor people are overweight because they
have worse foods and because garbage
food is cheaper and that's not
necessarily true but it's somewhat true
right and so i was talking to a lefty
friend and here's how they explained it
and i think it's actually a decent point
but needs to be fact checked norman
borlaug was this famous scientist who uh
figured a way to increase crop yield so
that your typical plant produced way
more like so wheat would produce like
four times the yield all of a sudden
there's way more starch and sugars
available for people but the nutritional
density stayed the same that meant that
poor people were buying the same kind of
food at the same price but there was
like half the amount of folate or
thiamine or whatever in it so they'd
have to they have to buy even more so
what happens is in order to get the same
level of nutritional density they have
to eat a ton of this starchy food and
sugary and fatty food and they gain a
bunch of weight from it right i actually
uh that makes sense to me i'm like why
is it that poor people are overweight
and they're like well the food they eat
is bad and i'm like bro you could buy
tomatoes lettuce and avocado for the
same price as a big mac meal or whatever
and then you real you think about it
it's like
when they're buying grains and breads
and stuff the nutritional density being
lower means they're they're struggling
they're eating a lot more of the same
stuff so it's like it's like half true
because i do think people could make
better choices but it still is not easy
for people who don't know why what
they're eating has become bad for them
well there's also this weird thing where
we're obsessed with finding new things
to turn corn into yeah right we're like
what is this food like maybe we could
make it out of corn instead yeah it's
like we have plastic and it's polluting
the world what if we made corn
into plastic
actually a good idea foreign subsidies
yeah it's like are there other ways to
do it we we have a society of that's
going back to earth worshiping and child
sacrifices
yep well actually i disagree which
brings me to the next story we have
from interactive polls on twitter
generic congressional ballot trends
before versus after roe v wade decision
take a look at this republicans and
democrats in june 21
it was republican plus four
on june 27 it was republican plus five
republicans gained one point after
scotus overturned roe v that's
technically not true
democrats lost a point after the roe v
wade decision interesting so that is
interesting
why is it the republicans were like i'm
cool with that and democrats were like
we're mad at democrats over this
that's that's the progressive left
pulling the the centrist uh moderate
democrats over in the left field i saw
that a lot i didn't i didn't realize
until i started watching well i didn't
start watching you know per se but i
watched the young turks about a month
ago and the whole roe v wade thing was
was first breaking out when the document
got leaked and anna caspet what's her
name
yeah yeah me and her got into a huge
twitter back and forth and
when i watched it i realized that the
left pundits were talking less about
republicans or trumpers and they were
talking more about
the uh the the this you know contentment
they had with joe biden and the
establishment democrats and that's just
a way for them to to pull them over into
into left field and i think when i watch
joe biden talk now i can see that he's
not so much speaking against the right
as he's trying to appease the far left
yeah yeah well joe biden is weird right
because for so long he's adopted these
far left positions and he said things
about how we need to like affirm
children which is just another way of
saying that you should be able to push
them through gender transitions that
kind of thing um he's also extremely
radically pro-abortion he wants to
repeal the hyde amendment which prevents
federal funding from uh from going
towards abortions and then
when the polling data starts to make it
clear that these positions are unpopular
he comes out at the state of the union
and says defund the police no man i got
to defend the police and talking about
how we need to secure the border and
basically taking trump's platform yeah
so the man he doesn't stand for anything
right chameleon that's why he falls for
everything exactly like falling off the
stairs more than once
a bike that wasn't moving
well his foot got caught in the in the
clip he tripped so i'll give him that
one you trip easier when you're at that
age yeah yeah i just what happened with
the bike is that he has his pedal clips
and when he stopped he tried he took his
left foot out and then he leaned right
as he was trying to pull his right foot
out but he didn't get it out and so he
fell over
i it happens to people it's more likely
to happen to if you're old but it wasn't
like he was just standing there and just
fell down right you know what i mean
right yeah i just think
i think i'd like to see a little more
proficiency in bicycle riding from the
man leading the free world and walking
upstairs yeah well i supposedly never
forget how to ride a bike but i guess
dementia is another story so look like
brutal i think it's fair to say the dude
fell down but i want to point out his
foot got stuck in a bike
the american military given his credit
but it's not it's not about the point
it's not like he was riding his bike and
then just went
and fell over no no he was standing but
that's also why people are joking about
it because he was like standing still
when he fell over he should have leaned
on his left foot and pulled his right
foot out or had some some sort of
cognizance to not lean into it as he
started to fall but he didn't have his
card that said he's holding your left
foot up
no one told him
i think he made a good point royce that
the democratic party is kind of turning
on itself uh and you see that in the
colbert interview like they've just
completely dismissed joe biden and kamal
harris they're not even mentioned of
those people they're they've agreed
they're useless they're not going to run
in 2024.
it's hilarious go ahead no it says biden
they're they're all sitting around a
table and they're like so who's running
in 2024 and biden goes oh i'm going to
run for reelection and they go yeah yeah
so he's running in 2024 like he's just
sitting there like he's not in the room
you know what i mean
i think these two were always the
cutouts
i think fight and combat yeah i think
they were always transitory cutouts from
the beginning sacrificial yeah
candidates
i mean if you just look at their records
look at how easy it would be to dislike
them over the course of their
administration it's almost like the
democratic party is casting upon joe
biden all of their sins so they can have
like the slaves
sacrifice as a candidate and they can
bring someone else in to fix the problem
why would that be far-fetched for people
like this is what troubles me and we
talked about this a little bit last time
do we think that george soros or klaus
schwab or these international governing
bodies and and these uh eclectic
metropoli but metropolitan omnisexuals
don't think four
years and eight years ahead
like is that really tough for us to
graft it is because most people live in
this sort of radical materialist
everyday lifestyle where they do eat
these fatty foods and they do play on
their video games and they do you know
get the the immediate instant
gratification from their social media
likes or whatever so it's hard for them
to imagine a group of people who are
effective and thinking that far ahead
because they don't do it but these
people have proved that they are willing
to do it and they're very effective at
doing it i think that joe biden was
always a cutout
from the very beginning i think that's
why they uh undermined bernie in the in
the in the uh democratic uh election
when when joe bide ran i think when he
resigned from the in 1988 when he was
running against george bush senior and
resigned because he was found out to be
a plagiarist is the entire industry gave
up on him and basically turned him into
a cardboard cutout like they realized
he's nothing more than a cutout at this
point maybe we'll use him at some point
he came out 2008 to run against obama
they put him up there as like the token
old white businessman and then yeah he
was the establishment guy right because
obama was too new and radical at least
in his rhetoric at least that's one
people like aoz yeah just like
yeah exactly but obama right he was like
the fringe radical anti-establishment
guy and people were worried and so he
goes with the most pro-establishment
cardboard cutout that he could find
i i do want to point out i pull up the
real clear politics average of polls
because that one poll was was i think
that was just iowa right
so in the real quick politics average
after the ruling republicans went up
about a half point democrats actually
made a fairly decent gain in aggregate
they went from 41.3 to four so they went
up one point republicans went up a half
point republicans made a gain on this
one democrats made it again in this one
but republi so democrats closed the gap
a little bit republicans still have a
2.5 uh point advantage in the generic
ballot which
is just apocalyptic
when democrats are leading by five
points they lose seats so anything short
of a five-point advantage from democrats
that's break even right now it's it's
just every day looking apocalyptic for
democrats to tell things have changed so
much about who's a democrat and who's a
republican now that it's the people that
like care enough to virtue signal that
they will fill out one of these polls
they tend to be democrats in the past
it's now but it's an aggregate poll so
so this is combining all the different
polls
so that's what's interesting about this
i don't i don't take just a single poll
where like fox news has to ask somebody
no this is hugo politico npr pbs
trafalgar rasmussen usa today fox news
and quinnipiac all of those different
polls with different methodologies and
they average it out that's your best
indicator but did they include real
patriot polls from real
patriot.blogspot.com
real patriot dot
patriot.infowarrior.website.website
and it's like 97 say donald trump is the
best three percent say donald trump is
pretty good
i got i got an email from trump and i'm
i bet most of you have gotten this too
and it was like
please fill out this poll how well do
you think donald trump is doing really
like that he's doing fantastic he's
doing great he's doing pretty good he's
doing all right and i'm like it's only
positive the only options were like he's
doing good in some way gotta love it
yeah i know that's trump man yeah that's
a trump my fear right now in politics is
that again to reiterate the ability for
people to look ahead the establishment
to look ahead that a lot of these
republicans are not really republicans
or they're not really conservatives i
think that a lot of the republic i think
it's
it's understood that the political the
politics in america are going to go in
ebbs and flows
and that right now the republicans are
on the rise
and they're going to
do everything they can within the
republican establishment to put people
forward who may even say that they're
america first
but really aren't
and i'm seeing that in my own primary
but i see it as i look even across some
of the people that joke that donald
trump endorsed like oz
right these people these people don't
really fundamentally understand the
ideas of america or the foundational
values of america
and and if they come to power even if
it's a republican-held uh you know house
senate
presidency uh america could still be on
a losing track with republicans in
office because the republicans have been
in on it oh yeah well we sort of joked
about this a while ago when we were
first going through this this polling
data uh which suggests that there will
likely be russian interference but when
we were looking through this polling
data i was just kind of joking about the
fact that yeah i know the republicans
might win in a landslide so they can not
do anything so they can just keep not
doing anything sit in their hands and
just say slow down they're not come on
you're going too far to be fair though
you know i do rag on mitch mcconnell he
did basically yeah get this roe v wade
thing it's true we were talking
my issue though is like partly the
reason i was thinking about this like
you know i'm still ragging on mitch for
republicans he actually he actually got
this for them for me that wasn't a big
issue for me the issue was like you know
i'm i'm more libertarian i'm not
conservative so for me roe v wade i'm
rather dispassionate on it goes back to
the states i'm kind of like okay that's
federal government rescinding authority
there's probably a lot of good things in
that my answer to democrats on the left
is they should be filing lawsuits at the
state level on the same grounds at the
federal level and then win in the states
what i want to see is republicans when
on policy grounds that they just don't
engage on they don't they haven't
engaged at all on the social media
censorship they just spin around in
circles they're caving on gun rights so
for me i just don't see anything
auditing the federal reserve i mean i'll
take it let the economy flounder like
this that's that's the ultimate failure
of a politician right now is to let the
economy fly so you're saying that you
think
because the roe v wade issue
is well the roe v wade issue was
illegitimate in its inception that's
number one so for mitch mcconnell to
back this
isn't necessarily as extreme as it
as it seems
due to the public you know the public's
view of it now but constitutionally it's
not really an extreme position
as say him being more america first on
trade or other policies mitch mcconnell
played the judge game and republicans
played the judge game and ignored the
cultural issues the cultural issues have
a big impact on me so i'm biased
for conservatives who are pro-life
they they they were ragging on mitch
mcconnell and republican leadership over
the culture war issues but then when
they get this victory on roe v wade
they're like oh okay what they did
worked for us for me roe v wade wasn't
one of my issues so i'm like gun rights
free speech you know uh schools and all
that stuff what are you doing on these
issues that i'm worried about so i
acknowledge that's my bias mitch
mcconnell was very effective in getting
the roe v wade decision for
conservatives that's a fact yeah for the
recent gun decision too right the recent
gun decision absolutely it's a fair
point yeah it makes it through the
courts it doesn't go as far as uh i'd
like it to but i'm like okay those are
those are decent victories i do think
and and so credit where credit is due as
much as i'm still not a big fan of the
republicans because policy wise they do
very little the judges did get some
victories but if the republicans aren't
adequately engaged in the in cultural
issues and if the republican leadership
won't go after joe biden they won't go
after the corruption then like that's
that's that's where i'm you know very
concerned like congratulations you won
in the courts you know pro-lifers got
their thing pro-gun people got got their
thing what about joe biden being corrupt
what about the corruption from the
establishment after donald trump why
didn't the republicans do more to to to
stop what was happening in in in this
system
i i focus on that
they're in on it oh yeah yeah they're in
on it that's why oh i mean you look at
pennsylvania the republican establi you
look at robbie starbuck the republican
establishment does not like trump maga
and the populist uh republicans and they
want they're they're okay within it the
the two sides of the coin is that the
left has traded the and this is the this
is a problem for most american people
but you can see it very well in the
political dichotomy the left has traded
their freedom for
materialism
and the right or the republicans have
traded their freedom for security both
versions are an expansion of government
most people have become okay with the
idea that their american citizenship
depends on the expansion of government
and mitch mcconnell is all for the
expansion of government this is the
funny thing when uh when aoc and pelosi
say that the supreme court is extremist
or illegitimate and i see these memes
where they're like the supreme court has
stripped the rights away and i'm like
actu actually they didn't the supreme
court said the federal government
doesn't have this authority it's
actually anti-fascism like if you claim
you're antifa
and you don't like authoritarianism and
all that stuff the federal government
being like we hereby rescind this power
should be a good thing but oh no that
meant states now have have control over
these situations and they don't like
what actual decentralization means
what so when these antiform left people
and leftists come out
and they're saying things like
we shouldn't have these authoritarian
systems
they're actually saying we should
because if you were to get rid of the
federal government and decentralize
everything then all of a sudden smaller
jurisdictions take take authority in how
they want to run things and all of a
sudden you'll find
when you get rid of the centralized
authority you're going to see white only
towns you're going to see anti-lgbtq
towns you're going to see no more roe v
wade in red states what they really are
saying is they want the federal
government to enforce their ideology on
everywhere their own politics that's
right that's exactly right well exactly
and when you look at the uh the
democratic party platform
and what they're pushing for with
respect to abortion i don't think it's
unfair to say that the actual party
platform more or less suggests that
for any child
any unborn child in any part of the
country to have any kind of legal
protection is a travesty for there to be
any unborn child anywhere in the country
that can't be killed is a miscarriage of
justice from their perspective it's evil
it's just evil it's it's it's just i'm
sorry man it's just so weird
and it's it's rooted i can only say it's
written in ignorance
people in blue states are unaffected by
the roe v wade decision in fact the
decision likely will cause democratic
politicians to expand abortion access in
blue states
so that what they're basically saying is
people in places where i don't live
should be allowed to get access to a
procedure most of those people don't
want exactly because again for whatever
reason
any innocent faultless unborn child
having any legal protection is abhorrent
to them they can't stand it they can't
tolerate it so
here's the problem with the republicans
we talked about mitch mcconnell he got
some some major policy victories um and
the republican leadership did and i'll
tell you uh
the one of the issues is i've totally
lost my train of thought what were you
talking about roe v wade
yeah i lost what i was gonna say i
forgot oh
that's because i keep thinking yeah well
i think no i was gonna i was gonna say
that this this roe v wade one is not
even a judgment call in my book agreed
the morality of it is very clear okay i
remember what i was gonna say go i got
it back i got it back because i'm
reading i'm like reading these polls
okay i forgot again go ahead oh no
no no no no i'm kidding
i'm kidding i'm kidding we were talking
about the success of the republicans
republicans are are running on moderate
policy mitch mcconnell may have got a
victory but i think this should i should
make this statement the fact that you
sheamus think it was a victory that half
the country is allowed to murder babies
shows the problem i don't think that
that's a vic i think it's a i do think
it's a victory in a step in the right
direction but it is absolutely not going
far enough it's not right but here's
what i mean it's not murder it is yeah
okay hold on not legion
my point is if conservatives do believe
that regardless of your opinion ian
they've accepted that half the country
will be allowed to do it and they're
like yay we won this one instead a real
victory would have been the supreme
court coming out and being like
all human life has constitutional
protections whether they're in the womb
or out therefore taking the life is a
violation of the constitution that would
have been a much better victory agreed
if a if if a human has a lot so
life liberty pursuit of happiness what
then then the actual conservative
position would be for the supreme court
to come out and say that's right a a
human unborn baby is still a human and
it would be a violation of the law and
the constitution to end its life or to
grant the right to do so ergo the
supreme court would have said nationwide
it actually this actually makes more
sense
the constitution granting protection to
women to get abortions makes less sense
than the constitution granting rights to
a human being not to be killed yeah
however the conservative court didn't
even rule that they said leave us out of
it and the left is saying the
republicans are extremists no the left
are the extremists the republicans are
happy to accept a moderate victory
meaning we'll take what we can get in
our red states and you do your thing
whereas the left says we want total
domination nationwide and that's that's
that's what i was saying to begin with
that roe v wade and its inception was
illegitimate and that it they're making
it seem like it being overturned as a
far right
a far right policy position when really
it's the lukewarm moderate position
agreed and so therefore mitch mcconnell
actually shouldn't get the same credit
that
that that he may get in in our view but
the the the
the point that i think needs to be
driven home about
abortion
is that
when a society loses the sanctity of
life
you can't have a precept of human rights
and civil rights legitimately totally
society is based on the slaughter of the
native population they're all humans
they were all humans but they didn't act
like they were true no and that and that
was a
that was um protestant christians taking
the lord's name in vain it's not an
indictment of god and it's not an
indictment of america it's an indictment
of those
few men who chose to use the lord's name
in that way at that time but it still
doesn't change the universal truth about
life whether it be native whether it be
american unborn today or whether it be
blacks during slavery
the precept of human rights and civil
rights has to be dependent on a sanctity
of life if you don't have the sanctity
of life it doesn't only allow you to
justify killing a
human fetus which is is an infowar of
biblical proportions but it also allows
you to kill faceless people by double
tap drone strikes in afghanistan yeah so
yeah so i want to i want to
jump on that but first i want to respond
to what tim said because i think you
make a great point
yeah i'm going to respond well hold on
so so
i don't think that's entirely fair i
agree with your assessment completely
that the conservative pro-life position
is and should be that abortion must be
illegal nationwide i still think it's
it's perfectly reasonable to say thank
goodness that it can be restricted in
some places now we haven't gone all the
way with it this is not the end i
understand that yeah and uh my point is
just
republicans consistently fight for the
moderate exact quorum yeah the
compromise yeah and i would agree with
that i think that
leaving it up to the states is
ultimately the moderate position and i
don't think it makes a whole lot of
sense i have a question for you and for
conservatives
when do you think
when at what point does a person gain
constitutional rights uh i would say the
moment of fertilization yeah you're a
human being at that point what do you
think
yeah i would say the conception
what do you think ian uh when they get a
birth certificate why because that's
american citizens of american human
rights if your slaves didn't have birth
certificates yeah they didn't have those
same human rights they they were granted
it under the 14th amendment well
eventually they got them through after
the 14th amendment like there's no
amendment that says that a unborn fetus
has human rights but that but
i don't know if that's relevant so
you're asking me what i think morally it
should be not yeah he's asking for your
like uh priest well no no no no it's
fine that's why i i accept your answer
when they get a birth certificate when
they're born so my question is just like
why when they're born you know like why
is that the case
because um
yeah why when they're when they're
that's when they start contributing to
society
i i don't think so i think yeah that's a
rat season the problem the problem with
with it with that viewpoint
is
it's a radical materialist mentality and
what what you're basically saying is
that your only value as a human being
is your contribution to society and and
that is a that is a predicate for the
fourth industrial revolution whether
people want to consider it or not this
whole abortion argument is really a
predicate for the fourth industrial
revolution to be able to other
human beings based on their level of
productivity and justify killing them by
food whether it be big pharma maybe a
pandemic uh whatever the nuclear war uh
health freedom climate whatever it is
the ability to
judge and rule somebody based on what
they contribute to society solely as the
the anchor of their human rights or the
fundamental claim of human rights
is is just about as anti-human as you
can get i don't know because what if
they start tapping people's brains with
neural net reading minds doing
pre-thought crime and they do it to
babies in the womb and they're like that
baby had an illegal thought when it was
two months old it's going to be it's now
arrested
there'll be no neural net if i'm in
congress that's inherently that's a
heresy to begin with so let's
let me pull this story we have from
timcast.com
anna navarro doubles down on comments
about aborting special needs babies
she went on to say that she has a she
says quote i have a brother who's 57 and
has the mental and motor skills of a
one-year-old and i know what that means
financially emotionally physically for a
family i have a step-granddaughter who
was born with down syndrome and you know
what it's very difficult in florida to
get services it is not as easy as it
sounds on paper i've got another i've
got a step grandson who's very autistic
this was her example for why there needs
to be abortion effectively saying that
all of these people should be dead all
people have disabilities that's a
psychotic thing to say so so ian just a
moment ago you mentioned that
you know when a person is born is when
they gain constitutional rights my
question is
does the 57 year old man with the motor
skills of a one-year-old have
constitutional rights yeah do you think
he does yeah what about a baby born with
no brain yeah does it sound so still has
a name and a birth certificate but a
baby
with a full functioning brain that
functions more so than a born baby that
has no brain
the unborn like so let's say that says
two women and they and they're both
sitting there both equally as pregnant
as each other
and one baby is born
and the other was not but they're they
they were fertilized the exact same time
the one still in the womb has a fully
functioning brain and the one outside of
the womb has no brain just just the
cerebellum so it's basic motor functions
you think the one without a brain does
have constitutional rights and the one
in the womb does not yes so
then killing the one in the womb is fine
it's it's more ethical than killing the
living human yeah so
i accept your answer but i don't
understand it no i do it and
and i'm and
i don't say this to be disparaging at
all because you're my boy i like you
here it comes no i do i i like you um
but this is that whole
sapiens uh noah yuval harari school of
thought
is that um
reality can only be measured by
suffering
right
and like that's the ultimate form of
measurement of of reality yeah and so
the the suffering argument is
whatever we can do to eliminate
suffering to have to confront suffering
to have to confront anxiety and despair
whatever we can do to eliminate having
to go through that process that is
painful we'll do that and then we can
justify doing it to kids because most
likely if they're born into some
patriarchal white supremacy society
then they'll suffer
and my point is that
who do we think actually ends up dead in
those scenarios from these
white yuppy snowflake milk toasts
uniparty globalist establishment
politicians black people brown people
the numbers suggest that i i have a
thought experiment for you ian
so all right let's let's say right here
you've got two women they both conceived
they both had a baby conceived in them
at the exact same moments
one baby has no brain and is born and
the other baby has a brain totally
functioning completely average unborn
and you said that you think the one that
was born but doesn't have a brain has
more constitutional rights or does have
constitutional rights and the one unborn
doesn't
right yeah i think i don't know what the
law is about like a brain dead person
being born if the parent has the right
to kill it i'm going to pull it off
you believe that the baby that was born
even with no brain has constitutional
rights and the unborn has like ones born
prematurely with no brain no they're
both they're both nine months gestation
but one was born and the other wasn't
born yet because there's there's
variation so you're going to give the
rights to the born okay so thought
experiment a mad scientist comes in the
room and goes yeah and he fires a growth
ray at the other one now she's 70 feet
tall but the baby stayed the same size
her womb is now a giant open room and
they bring in a tv and a table and the
baby's still there and then someone
raises the baby but still in the womb
the baby learns to read and write does
it does it have constitutional rights
yet
no not by modern day law but by your by
your opinion should it with growth raise
um no
i have to rewrite the law my point is
i'm trying to understand why you don't
think that baby has any rights if the
womb became as big as a skyscraper due
to a mad sign there's an alien blast
like ah and she turns into a building
and the baby is still technically in the
womb but it's massive now and people
walk inside and they're teaching it math
and reading and it's and it's aging and
eating food you it has no rights
still in the womb i mean
this is interesting because if you can
neural net a baby and and track its
thoughts in the womb we're going to have
a
it'll be a revolution of what a baby is
is it a human is it alive does it have
rights yeah it will at that point
because we're able to communicate with
it but if you can't communicate with it
it doesn't have for all intents and
purposes right yeah i don't know man
sometimes we have difficulty
communicating but i think
[Laughter]
the point i'm trying to make just is i
do not understand the logic behind why a
baby at nine months
with with a with a thin layer of flesh
between its face and a per and everyone
else does not have any rights because
it's attached to the mom but the baby
that was born is still attached to the
mom too
well yeah i guess but it's about to be
removed no that's i didn't say they've
decided
it's not in the chord no they don't cut
the chord it stays it has no rights well
eventually you gotta cut the chord sure
sure sure but for in that moment it has
no rights i don't know what the process
is could you abort a baby that was born
as long as you don't cut the umbilical
cord god in some places but i don't
think that would be legal i just don't
understand why a baby at nine months
with a fully functioning brain that can
understand music that can kick and moves
around and is literally no different
physically than a baby at the exact same
time of gestation but is outside the
womb they're identical in every way i
don't understand where the separation of
rights is
let's forget the rights for a second
because i don't like the rights argument
because the left doesn't believe in the
constitution good point first of all
they believe the constitution is always
in flux and our constitution is
amendable in some ways but they believe
in a completely relativistic view of the
constitution and even claim that the
constitution itself
is illegitimate in its inception due to
slavery the natives and white supremacy
so i don't like the rights discussion
let's just make it more basic
who are the most vulnerable people
in the world
children young children unborn children
babies
what what scenario in a movie
makes us the most angry
when a dog gets hit by a car
yeah
for the liberal for the liberal yuppie
vegan cult cats for sure but but but for
me when i'm watching a movie the
characters that we just that that we
despise the most traditionally are
characters that kill a woman who has who
is pregnant or has her children with her
um
you know in some gruesome fashion and
there's a reason for that
and people don't want to give it its
proper credit but abrahamic faith
changed the trajectory from of our
society away from a barbaric child
sacrificing culture that's the story of
abraham he goes up into the mountain and
before abraham child sacrifice was a
common practice in barbaric societies
but how else are you going to get the
the grain to grow that's right you know
but that's exactly what they're doing
they're sacrificing babies for economic
growth that's their whole argument oh
it's like the resources for them the
harvest what was that what was that
was a book i think i know what you're
talking about yeah they would like the
springtime and they would like sacrifice
the young woman or whatever but my point
is that the the this this whole abortion
thing
is not about rights and it's not about
republicans and democrats this is an
informational war waged on women
yeah this is a this is a spiritual war
waged on women and to attack men
and the significance of legacy and
lineage
and and and procreation which is one of
the most miraculous gifts that that any
species has human or not but ours is
certainly special given how special
humans have proven themselves to be
scientifically speaking even take away
the faith and the divinity
but this is not about
any of the politics really this is an
attack on women to try and convince
women
that their sole
political power is anchored on their
ability to kill their children
and and there is nothing more
anti-human
anti-american and satanic than to tell
women
all of your political standing should be
dependent on this one
right
to kill
the most important thing and function
you can do as a woman and their argument
is
that the primary function of being a
woman shouldn't be bearing a child
that you know uh
abort if there can be no women's rights
without abortion rights and it's
it's it's it's strange to me that people
don't see how anti-human that really is
is
having a child
is
one of the most amazing things that ever
happened to me i have four but most
women say that about child bearing and
and for us to have reverse psychology
convinced an entire generation of women
that their rights their their political
power is anchored on the right to kill
an unborn child is is completely absurd
it's a bit unfair you know the real
issue is that everyone knows humans die
if they don't have sex like eating so
the women have no choice they have no
choice but to have sex without
protection and then get pregnant
yeah yeah well right they talk about so
they so if they're going to succeed in
the workplace they need to be able to
terminate their pregnancies
or they can you know in all seriousness
just use a condom an iud birth control
or what about
why is the application of science so
relative
right because you're never hearing these
arguments about abortion or you know sex
or you know family planning
don't we have reasonable methods to to
measure ovulation we do yep we do i mean
not down to a science and there are
there are exceptions but but the
ovulation scheduling is is pretty is
pretty
thorough uh and and pretty sure fire in
most cases and that's never even
mentioned that we should use science in
that way they go immediately to let's
kill unborn children not let's use the
advancement of science to to regulate or
track ovulation i've got i've got a
potential hypothesis here why is it that
the left that is more likely to abort
their kids less likely to even get
pregnant more likely to get vasectomies
more likely to get their tubes tied why
are they so adamant about there being
abortion access in red states why are
they so adamant about teaching lgbtq
issues to children
i think these people recognize a very
important thing
they don't have kids
they need republicans to abort their
babies otherwise in 20 years the future
is conservative
if the left is more likely to be lgqt
lgbtqia 2 plus bb or whatever it is
those people are less likely to have
children
if they are already more likely to get
abortions if they do get pregnant all or
more likely to use prophylactics and get
vasectomies they're going to have
substantially less kids
over time conservatives having kids
means this country will be conservative
that's why they need to advocate for red
states to allow abortion so they can try
and stop republicans from having kids
and they can advocate for young
conservative women to don't ruin your
life
you you you've got your whole future out
if you have a child later get the
abortion now that was an info award that
the catholic church is somewhat
responsible for too
christianity
this whole child out of wedlock thing i
don't like it
i'm a christian i'm a cat i think that
the entire cultural motif of shunning
or or bastardizing
child children that were born out of
wedlock was a predicate for abortion
well so i definitely think that we
should not be shaming pregnancy we
should be shaming adultery adultery was
the part that was wrong the getting
pregnant part it's not but but but
culturally no i hear you i hear humans
made you know that's how you knew if
someone was yes
they looked at the the child born out of
wedlock as another exactly they didn't
they didn't separate the sin of the
parents from the the divinity of the
childbirth very sad and that that that
was a that that that's how you have an
avalanche of cultural decay and
misinformation that ends up being well
you know and even conservatives
christians catholics you know well you
had that child out of wedlock anyway go
ahead and abort the kid that's very safe
that's fair i i think the
in the next 30 years this country is
going to be christian conservative
so um it's an example i've given before
but for the context i'll say it again
in the early 2000s a survey was done it
found that liberals were having i think
1.54 kids or something like that on
average and conservatives were having
2.01
that meant that conservatives were at
replacement levels and liberals weren't
20 years later we get this poll that
shows or about 20 years later 18 years
that uh gen z is slightly more
conservative than millennials but only
slightly they're very very similar and a
lot of people assumed that meant that
gen z was based that they were waking up
that the culture war message was getting
to them but that's not reality the
reality is conservatives just had more
kids ergo more conservative gen z that's
it simple math so what we see from the
left is an attempt to indoctrinate kids
because leftists don't have children
they have yours
now we're seeing them attempt to get red
states to enact an abortion abortion
rights because they want republicans to
abort their kids
otherwise what you get
right now today the left is
substantially more likely to not have
kids like the i was looking at a graph
and it's like it's plummeted but
conservatives are actually fairly stable
though it has gone down just give it 18
more years 18 years from today it's
going to be 2040. we're all going to
still be
we're going to be
middle-aged
and we're going to be seeing a
substantially more conservative country
yeah but i don't think it's going to be
christian conservative yeah i will i
doubt it dude ancient religions are on
their way out hand that rocks the cradle
rules the world but that's right yeah
bro yeah but sense nonsense okay maybe
maybe muslim way
it's been here for two thousand years i
know it's time for something new man how
long well nonsense
nonsense fades away it's been two
thousand years what's going on
the byzantines dude
literally proven him correct about what
statement he didn't even he says it
persists and nonsense fades away but it
also became the orthodox church it's
obvious that the romans are are the
patriarchy like the roman catholic
church was created to suppress and
control people and you're praying what
you were saying about marriage today
demonizes children born out of wedlock
you've proved sheamus's point he wasn't
making a point he was we were just
having a conversation what he made a
point which
i said because christians are having
children more than the left the future
will be christian conservative yeah but
that's james so one plus one equals two
argument that's not how humans works
said the hand that cradle rocks the
world and you you disagreed and said
it's fading away then you went on to say
that despite all of the things that
happened throughout history
the religion persisted and evolved and
was changed and all of that whether it's
true or not you're arguing that instead
of fading out and dying it was
reinvigorated and re-embraced and
expanded to the point where it's bigger
than it's ever been throughout history
because there was universal truth
beneath the sins
there was a truth that that persisted
throughout the ages beneath the sins and
in the same way
the
sins of the roman empire are not an
indictment of god the sins of our
founding fathers are not an indictment
of america
there there is a difference between
ideas and the application of those ideas
and then this is something that even
conservatives have had trouble trying to
articulate to people who don't
necessarily believe in god
many people who don't believe in god
don't necessarily believe in a
traditional view of america or american
citizenship and it is a great infowar
slavery is not an indictment of
america's foundational values in fact
the constitution was used to justify
freeing the slaves so it actually
vindicates that our constitution and our
american founding values were were
brilliant and and were inclusive in in
some ways and were humane but the
application of them in the early stages
was certainly not but but those things
aren't an indictment of the ideas
uh themselves and the i and certainly
not an indictment of god
well i know a lot of people that call
themselves christian that go to church
and then they get wasted and like you
[ __ ] your body's a temple really like
is that that's the point
you want to say that you're completely
true and that they'll just go like
christians don't need to worship christ
you don't need to worship jesus to be a
christian does it say nothing drink beer
in the bible no so yeah you you cannot
drink to the point of excess you can't
get drunk which is to say yeah which is
to say you can't drink to the point
where you are no longer able to make
good decisions right and how insane like
come on
that's like the biggest hypocrite
criticism of like
modern culture people call them so
christian then they destroy themselves
like come on well all yeah i mean look
there have been hypocrites in the
christian faith throughout all of
history judas is one of the the first
bishops right and he betrayed christ
i don't know that's all ancient text
stuff man i don't know if it's real or
not 230 to 250 million americans are
christian
and so
i think one important point is that
while the percentage may be lower than
it was before
of peop there are still substantially
more christians but
i'm a christian and i i've taught god as
much as anybody who comes on here
probably uh somewhat but
um i agree with you
my point's not even not even to bring up
religion in the first place my point was
that
as as james said the hand that uh people
who identify as christian conservatives
are going to be the majority identify
but i agree with you when you say
that a lot of people who say they're
christian
don't necessarily follow the laws of the
faith
so yeah they're just like there's a
referendum on what it means to be
american if we even want to have a
country and that is the referendum right
now do we want to have a country there's
a referendum on christianity and what it
means to be christian what it means to
be catholic they're having that argument
in the vatican right now there is going
to be an ongoing argument about what it
means to be or identify with these
institutions and these cultural beliefs
uh again that's not an indictment of the
beliefs themselves it's it's it's an
indictment of man's application of
belief i think the
the ideals of christianity are
impossible to embody i i i i'm
the the the argument about religion
itself is is is not relevant to the
point i'm trying to make the point i'm
trying to make is that
christians are having children whether
they truly believe in the bible is
totally immaterial what matters is the
left ideology will die because they
don't have kids therefore they argue for
red states where there are more
christians to have abortion access
because that will result in more
christians having abortions whether or
not they believe in there's going to be
there's going to be some young christian
girl who's like i don't have a baby i
don't have i'm going to go do it.
if it's illegal she's going to go to her
parents and say what do i do and they're
going to say we're going to support you
you're going to have the baby this is
the i think a a big reason whether
they're conscious of it or not there are
probably people on the left who realize
since the 2000s we have slowly been
eroding the the leftist movement has
been eroded they're tr they i mean
if you look at a lot of the left
movements it's always been about
eradicating religion
but they're losing because they don't
have kids the so this is why the school
choice fight is so
important for the democrats they can't
allow people to take their kids out of
schools and choose where they want to go
this is why they're freaking out over
the supreme court decision in maine that
allows people to get public funding and
choose whatever school they want release
or otherwise this is why they're
freaking out about a coach who prayed
for himself and students decided they
wanted to pray with him they said no
he's leading them in prayer no he was
praying they also decided to pray people
are allowed to speak you can't stop them
or fire them from doing it they're
losing
they're not having kids
and with the internet
christians christian conservatives or
even hypocritical christian
conservatives if they call themselves
that still are
expanding growing and defending their
values defending their kids is also why
they're so freaked out about the don't
say gay lie
because they're like we need to
indoctrinate their kids because we don't
have any and this is why they're
screaming don't say pray universal laws
and and the real scary part is in my
opinion it's a stop gap
because if the lgbtqism indoctrination
doesn't work they're going to be the
ones who abandon the idea of democracy
the fastest believe
that the push for artificial
intelligence and this whole
automation-driven transhumanism
idea is the um
is the
uh plan b you could say uh no no pun
intended it's the plan b for if the
indoctrination doesn't work and in the
automation ai world there will be no
more democracy and that's what they plan
on doing and that's what you see
um many many factions of our government
doing right now and going after
conservatives like steve bannon it's
just we're going to create a banana
republic where the ideas of justice
democracy freedom are completely
relative and we'll make them up as we go
yeah it feels like um we are headed
towards a more conservative future if we
do this right like things have gotten
way too wacky and like
ready for change you know at a drop of a
hat like we need to conserve our values
but the only the reason i brought up
that i don't think it would be a
christian conservative is because i
think people are bastardizing the word
christian calling themselves christian
on paper going sitting in a church
repeating words but they don't live like
i think you're well but you have to i
think i think you're biased i think you
have a negative view from immediate
depictions of what of what a christian
is
maybe you might be right about that
because like of the christians we've had
here has any one of them have been in
any way as you've described it
oh everyone's like no one's perfect yeah
you know
you tell me if i'm wrong but my concept
of being christian fundamentally is
do you believe in sin or don't you i
mean that's one of the that's one of the
anchors and so when you say that there
are christians who people who identify
as christian who are hypocrites the the
distinction there is that they believe
in sin and they may be sinning but they
do believe that it is a sin and that
there's a a metaphysical accounting that
they can then be redeemed from by by
having faith or by asking for repentance
and people who don't believe
they don't believe in a metaphysical
accounting and it's kind of uh most of
them believe in karma which is the same
thing essentially but they you know but
some people don't believe in
universal accounting at all and that's
dangerous i think they're they're
obviously fake christians there are
people who claim to support a lot of
ideas they don't support there's a lot
of people who are like who are woke who
say they hate racism but then they're
super racist there are a lot of people
who claim to be christian and you see
these videos of them you know screaming
and spitting on people i also think that
there is a media depiction of a
christian this is just outright not true
of all of the religious people we've had
come here not a single one of them was
as you described oh i mean we sit with
people for an hour and a half i don't
know those people yeah sure what do they
think about when they're alone in their
room at night like i don't know but
they've not screamed at you they've not
uh you you've not witnessed any of them
be as you've described christianity is
held it's a really weird thing you're
supposed to be like this benevolent
angelic thing that has no sin you've
washed away what we believe or you're
just guilty about right no no no no and
this is betraying the catholic church
you sit in front of sheamus all the time
and you say things like this is what
it's supposed to be but you've never
bothered to actually sit down with
sheamus and ask him what he believes
well i mean so much james believes that
when he drinks wine and eats bread it's
literally the body of jesus christ yeah
well i'm not dr eating one and drinking
bed in that instance but yeah no i do
believe in transubstantiation i i
believe in the the holy eucharist i do
like that so don't say that but you know
once that's
not relevant to the point i'm making the
point
a piece of bread is not literally a
human being
the point i'm making
is that sheamus does believe that and he
is not lying about what he believes and
you consistently depict christians as
like rabid
hey kid this bread is literally a human
body the kid's gonna be like i don't
believe that that's that's not what
we're talking about you're saying kids
are christian parents are gonna have
christian kids that's not how it works
when you lie to your kid and tell them
something is what it's not the kid sees
through it
that's not true so ian there there's a
couple
kids are impression uh impressed upon by
their parents and adopt their parents
values and there's just there's a few
things i want to mention because there's
something i really want to touch on here
to be christian
there's two tears here right you're sort
of discussing hypocrisy and hypocrisy is
a real phenomena but there's a
difference between being someone who
makes a mistake in sins which everyone
does and christians acknowledge that and
we call ourselves sinner and and someone
who says i actually don't believe this
is a sin i'm gonna do it anyway while
calling myself christians now you
insinuated earlier that i'm a hypocrite
because i drink even though nothing in
my faith prohibits drinking as long as
you're not getting drunk because you
don't know anything about my religion
you don't know what i believe because
you haven't take the time to ask me but
you were willing to make an accusation
about me in front of literally tens of
thousands of people i was told by a
catholic that i'm going to hell because
i don't believe jesus is the son does
that justify but does that justify any
of what i just said well i mean i'm sure
you're about changing my point i
my point is you made an accusation
towards me which in singing i don't know
what you're drinking i've seen you get
somewhat drunk it's not that big of a
deal but i i've i think you you drink to
the point where you're feeling a little
bit like happy or bubbly but you cannot
drink to the point where you're making
bad decisions dude i don't even care so
but the point is yeah yeah yeah i care
about people that are you brought it up
but you brought up exactly to insinuate
that i'm a hypocrite but you never stop
to ask me about any of this or what the
faith teaches and so i think that's
really unfair because we've known each
other for a long time and especially if
there is something you think i'm
hypocritical on then you have a
conversation with a person instead of
waiting until you're on air to try to
make an accusation i don't want to be
personal
but i then fair enough but i think what
matters most is you've known christians
who have said and done things to you
that have hurt you and i yeah i think
that stinks because look christians are
are human beings and we also make
mistakes i've seen christians
people for sure sure but but my point is
we don't become christian because we
believe other christians are perfect we
become christian because we believe in
jesus christ we believe that he's
perfect
that doesn't require but it doesn't
require believing that other people are
perfect that doesn't require being a
perfect person but the whole like
believing that jesus will is not what
makes you
anointed it doesn't give you the power
of annotation like so so i believe that
i got to stop you because this
conversation is not going anywhere the
point i made was ian
you you've asserted something about
christians that has not
appeared before you out of the entire
time we've done the show and had
numerous christians come on talking
about their faith
my question is how could you believe in
a a a general negative depiction of all
christians or or a large some of them or
a majority of them or a plurality when
you've not encountered any of those
stereotypes and any of the christians
that we've had come here and not just
the people who've been on the show but
even people who work here
that's what i don't know i've seen like
christians behave cruelly
cruelty people christians that are
lustful i've seen christians that are
and get angry which is wroth which is a
sin um
so wait what context you can ask in what
context is getting angry at saying roth
what wrath yeah so
wrath does not exclude
wrath does not um condemn
righteous indignation there are things
we should be angry about so you
basically are saying that
being angry at all is sinful and makes
christian hypocrite but again you don't
know what christians believe about anger
or wrath the the point is is just this
you've you've made several points on
several different shows
about christians generally being this
hypocritical or negative thing
even though
at the very least you could argue there
are you know you've actually met more
christians who are nice and do adhere to
their faith than who don't
but you still maintain the negative over
the positive i usually have good
interactions with people in general
because that's what i give people when i
enter i i just feel like if 250 million
people in this country identify as
christians
i don't think most of those people are
hypocritical i don't think i don't
really care
it doesn't make you a good person like
you can say
i'm a christian it doesn't make you a
christian that doesn't make you a good
person yeah not everyone who calls lord
lord will be saved but shame is you
would you agree with this and and i
think there are many catholic
theologians and and devout christians
who are much much more in alignment when
they're with their faith in their
everyday life than i surely am that
would
tell you uh in that
the decay of america or the decay of
society is the failure of the church
yeah
and 100 the hypocrisy of the church and
that that them not being the the moral
shepherd that they were supposed to be
in in a variety of ways
is partially and or mostly to blame for
how wayward society has has gotten um so
no nobody who is again what what i think
what tim is trying to say is that
nobody who's really christian who has a
well-formulated
world view on christianity is trying to
abnegate the culpability of christians
in the the wayward ways of the world at
all i think most christians in fact who
are real christians and not just virtue
signaling like the left does will tell
you no christians are actually to blame
for for how things have gotten i'll put
it this way kind of what i'm saying is i
grew up catholic i went to church what i
saw of christians
depicted on tv didn't make sense to me
because i did not know anybody at my
church who acted that way as the as the
media would would portray them
ian you've also not been to church have
you a few times yeah like you've
actually
when i was younger i went uh i went to
an outdoor catholic church once i went
to a methodist church once i went to a
youth group for often every sunday i
would go like for three hours the people
there were generally just mean kids and
they would play basketball so so i think
that's the example of it uh i see how
the left depicts christians i see how
jordan clepper and comedy central goes
to events and finds people to
caricaturize and mock and portray
negatively and then i think about the
people i met growing up then i think
about how i had this moment in my life
where our church actually kind of
slighted my family and my family stepped
away from them made me a bit angry and
it felt like these people were lying and
then i met someone who wasn't christian
who talked to me about jesus and i was
like oh
they were just bad people yeah people
like and then i realized something as i
started to travel around i remember
being at occupy wall street and seeing a
conservative pro-life protest and they
were all like oh man we're gonna go
there be careful we're infiltrating
that's the left said we shoved a bunch
of old ladies waving american flags and
they were waving and smiling and i was
like no these people are mean and then i
hear people
give general negative depictions of of
religious people i'm like i wonder if
that's just a negative media portrayal
stereotype because if 250 million people
in this country identify as christians
certainly not 250 million people are
walking around angry or hypocritical in
fact not even the majority or plurality
of them are
typically angry at least when you see
them in person on twitter yeah they've
probably got that angst and anger but
for the most part when you go outside
and touch grass the people you're
talking to probably christian and not
all that mean actually kind of nice if
you collapse in the middle of the street
in the middle of anywhere in this
country someone's going to run up and
try and help you for the most part in
some places they don't but what i mean
to say is
regardless of the religion i just think
it's absurd to characterize and
stereotype people as generally negative
and hold that view of them hypocrites
because people will tell me
they'll be like dude it doesn't matter
what i do i can do whatever i want
because if i believe in jesus he
forgives me when i die i've never said
that yeah kids growing up they were
taught by their parents from the church
like oh all all my sins will be forgiven
if i believe in jesus children yeah
other like friends high school kids and
whatever that's part of the reason why
it's a sin and that's part of the reason
why it's a sin and egregious to kill a
baby in the womb
because
because ch children
don't have a uh
what what what aquinas did
what he did for christianity what what
christianity solved was a merger between
uh uh
judaism you could say
and first principles of of greek and uh
uh aristotelian thought and it and and
the catholic belief the modern catholic
belief is that the holy spirit doesn't
exist in and of itself necessarily that
it is embodied and perfected with the
human
rational mind
and that to live and to think to have
thought to know god is actually the the
height and strive of christian and
catholic belief and when you rob a fetus
of their growth and maturity and faith
that is the ultimate sin
you've you've taken the innocence of a
child also the holy spirit does exist
external too uh like the holy spirit
does exist independent of us but yes
yes still works through us if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the show with your
friends head over to timcast.com sign up
to be a member we're gonna have a
members only show at 11 p.m it's the
after hours show where we swear and it's
not very family friendly but it is good
fun
and uh don't forget to follow us on
instagram uh timcast irl you can follow
me at tim kessler let's read some super
chats grofty says buck buck buck yes i
have good news for fans of chicken city
well it's sort of good news we've
created an outdoor area so the chickens
can get access to the mulberries it's a
fenced off area it won't keep them safe
at night
but during the day it keeps them
corralled so they can have fresh grass
and there are mule berries everywhere
and i had to chase these dumb little
things around today because they
wouldn't go back inside so yeah good fun
but uh that's good news for the chickens
of which there are many and we're also
starting cocktown
yeah we're going to try and figure out
cocktown it's a
the roosters yeah the roosters
what are you guys talking about
come on guys we're talking about
roosters each other like what's going on
oh you guys have dirty minds
the roosters can't live with the girls
because they'll fight so all of the boys
roosters also known as cox need to be
brought or cockerels to uh cocktail nice
and that's cox c-o-c-h
what [ __ ]
is that how you spell it's like cockrell
i think is the o-c-k-e-r-e-l
yeah
the inner ear is the cockerel c-o-c-h is
that right i don't know cochlear
cochlear all right let's see we got coke
mr sly tripp says why is abortion legal
the day before birth in colorado but
under hr 724 it's a federal crime to
intentionally stop a tote
it's true yeah oh my god it actually is
it's just so insane to me
don't stop toad man
oh man
okay okay okay
robert knight says as an independent
voter in colorado i got both ballots the
democrat ballot had one option per
position whereas the republican ballot
had multiple
interesting
all right khalil rose as if aoc becomes
present i'm moving to canada oh wait it
sucks there too it's even worse there
i don't know man uh luke's always
talking about chiron in mexico yeah it's
the anarchic state it's like they got no
government you just go there and live
there you go it's one way to do it el
salvador yo they got a place called
bitcoin beach where a bunch of like tech
entrepreneurs and bitcoin maximalists
and crypto heads are buying property in
el salvador because their economy is
booming their crime is is is decreasing
this is crazy when they introduced
bitcoin into el salvador apparently they
banked the whole country overnight like
all of a sudden the entire population
had access to a financial a digital
financial account and i i i was told
this fact checks out it was true that
they gave everyone 30 in crypto to
kickstart the bitcoin economy so all of
a sudden everybody starts spending money
like crazy and the economy just went
boom wow hey cryptocurrency man i love
it wow
and uh that's one way to get past the
federal reserve huh okay
all right storm
huffman says sheamus said to see you go
you have been a critic you have been
critical in making me look at
catholicism in a better light what is
your biggest criticism of the church oh
that well thank you very much and i i
really appreciate that that's a good
question so you know i i wholeheartedly
believe in catholicism in the catholic
church if if there's a criticism i have
it's basically just going to be with uh
the way the people
in the church behave the way all of us
behave but ultimately that's something
that's known to us based on
the scriptures right we we know that uh
the earliest christians they made
mistakes um we talk about judas and i
mentioned him as the first bishop well
look at the first pope peter i mean he
denied christ
three times before repenting right and
so
we have to
my biggest criticism of the church is me
if i was holier if i was better if i
followed in christ's footsteps
more effectively um i would be merely
more graces for the world and i think
ultimately if you are catholic your
biggest criticism of the church should
be yourself we are change says is potato
man leaving
potato man indeed i saw that he said he
can't take the heat well let me tell you
something luke
all right
you and i we'll do a little stream of
our own where we can hash some of this
out without the referee without tim
stopping us from going to town but yes i
am going to be leaving for a little
while and i know you're going to miss me
luke which is why i think you should go
to freedomtunes.com become a member for
five bucks a month he's sheamus actually
going on a mission to preach the good
word of freedom tunes yes not actually
the religion he wants you know to people
to watch exactly all right let's read
some more
pp storm says a pile of rocks is smarter
than aoc sure a picture of a pile of
rocks is smarter than aoc
all right the katy
kl tanker says please look into randy
cox and the new haven police another
reason we need constitutional carry
nationwide man ended up paralyzed for a
possession of a handgun without a permit
maybe more to story i think i saw that
was that the guy who was who was given
the nickel ride
he was there was a uh i don't know
there's a story where a guy was sitting
in the back seat of a wagon and the
police slammed the brakes on so he flew
forward and broke his neck
and it was for illegal possession of a
handgun and i read that story and i'm
like what's illegal about possessing a
handgun
did he lose his right to possess it
through due process or did they find a
guy who didn't have a permit so they
paralyzed him and the crazy thing is i
don't know if it's the same story but
this dude they dragged him out he's like
i can't move and they're like you're
fine and they drag him out yo when you
have a spinal injury they can't move
they're supposed to move you the
paramedics have to come in very
carefully because they can make it worse
the cops just drag him out
dude we got problems with police all
right i'll shout out
in these circumstances this stuff should
not be happening
but what do you do i guess the cops are
just they don't tolerate it because
people will lie and claim and like piss
themselves and stuff like that but
maybe what we need is
one emt
with every arrest is that we have to do
this guy he's paralyzed from the chest
down now
and when i saw the story i got really
mad because ben crump is involved and
i'm like you've lost all credibility but
regardless that shouldn't happen
yeah no i think
and i said this last time i think
policing has become a byproduct of a
system that
that is okay
with whatever level of moral decay and
chaos ensues and then they throw it on
the police and and not only do they
throw it on them but they actually uh
under train them and underfund them so
that they can be the scapegoat so
yeah policing has become one of the most
corrupt uh
things that that go on in the country
michael alio says when republicans win
this year they should codify into law
the other rights that dems are worried
will be taken away miscegenation
contraception etc dare dems to oppose it
as we remove their fundraising talking
points
yes
republicans should first of all codify
uh miscegenation which is mixed race
cohabitation and marriage and they
should be like democrats you're right we
hereby propose the bill for you
and then democrats will be forced to
oppose it won't they or they'll sign on
and have no talking point because then
these things won't be taken away and
contraception as well republicans can be
like yeah yeah these things are fine
what do you what do you think should the
republicans should codify cons right to
con contraception no no you don't think
so no i i just i don't think that's
fundamentally a conservative thing to do
well so there are numbers because the
thing is there are a number of
contraceptive methods that are
abortifacients too right that's true
what miscegenation you'd agree with
codify into law the right to mix race
marriage oh of course of course
yeah of course
take away their talking points
yeah well also the idea that like
republicans wanna would want to like ban
interracial marriage
like it's clearance thomas isn't an
integration it's because to them these
people are dumb everything is racist all
the time right they're they're they're
making memes while they're claiming
clarence thomas is just trying to get an
annulment from his wife that's hilarious
they're like he's trying to annul
miscegenation uh ruling so that his wife
it's like just get a divorce dude you
know what i don't think abortifaciens
are birth control that doesn't so
they're not fertilization control i
should say
birth control is a different thing you
want to make sure the baby isn't born
but that's kind of sickening almost or
con or fertilizer conceived right but i
think that there are a number of um
of birth control methods that do have
the capacity to be abortifacient so
there's somewhere it's like it's not
entirely clear if it's preventing
conception or if it's just aborting
immediately after the conception or
preventing implantation something like
that all right jordan ze says saw
catalina loft won her primary up here in
northern illinois i saw her a couple
weeks ago at my town's parade and i told
her i saw her on your show she said you
were cool hello i'll keep up the good
work that's cool you won a primary it is
a d plus 11 district
but considering the polling it very well
may flip
so i'm excited for make it happen
catalina you got to go out there you got
to knock on doors and you got to tell
everybody to vote for you
there we go
matthew velasquez says john cena
parodied trump on snl zolensky parodied
the presidency in ukraine
cena cortez 2024 why are they still
having trump on
on snl it's like it's just so weird to
me
yeah they're desperate they're hoping
he'll say something that the press will
report is true so that like they'll have
something to talk about like trump's snl
character says this i want i want to
call out james real quick yeah what do
you want to call him out do it right
jason says the rainbow is the biblical
symbol to noah as a covenant yeah i'd
like to see the rainbow more often
seamus put the rainbow behind you
why not
if it's like an actual rainbow and not
in the form of a game i mean look we
need to take it back folks we need to
take it back take it back it was never
exactly well in our culturally we have
unfortunately but yeah my issue is i
agree you should never allow them to act
to have me
there should be no nothing that they do
that says to you you can't use your own
symbols i would agree with you i would
agree i hate that they want to left high
diversity is another one right they've
hijacked diversity
and and it's obviously not a diversity
of thought it's a diversity of physical
representation or or uh
you know chosen identity but but yeah
that's another one that they've they've
hijacked
how about
we uh we reach out to one of our our
awesome fans who've done this this
woodworking for us and we get a a
rainbow that says god's covenant to noah
yeah beautiful let's do it i would 100
percent i will all right 100
it's it's it's it was a symbol of
christianity uh or abrahamic religion
before it was a symbol of anything else
right cultural cultural appropriation
exactly and what is the left able to do
all the left is able to do is steal and
twist
right they don't they originally take
other concepts they bastardize them they
destroy them how about you you make
flags that have a rainbow on it from
like edge to edge and there's an arc in
front of it and it says god's covenant
to noah yeah or not even the ark i mean
a little arc well i think cross or
something because i think the arc well
because i think if you put across people
would be like oh he's a pro lgbtq
christian but i think if it's i think if
it's the uh the ark then it's clear that
you're referring to the the flag as a
promise or the rainbow as a promise and
then if all christians started flying
that flag yeah yeah and then just it's
crystal
it's something that's
been a symbol no of god's covenant to
know they stole it well then you should
never have stopped using it well look i
was not the one who made that decision
and i think a lot of churches still do
so i'm i i don't want to give an update
i am working on getting that uh
lgbt pride video
up oh my goodness yeah yeah so the issue
is a copyright so just trying to figure
out
where we can find a video that has
cleared of copyright and um i'm really
interested to hear what these ad
agencies will have to say they're going
to say that's inappropriate i'll be like
but there are children there certainly
you don't think pride is inappropriate
for children do you
there are children at the event say it
say it publicly let me post that email
where the ad agency says we think pride
parades are inappropriate for children
i'd love to show everyone what you think
so it's a question of like
if an ad agency denies
showing this ad
then people aren't going to understand
because they're not going to see the ed
all they're going to know is that a
company tried putting up a video of a
pride parade with children that was
family friendly and the ad agencies
refused to do it or the ad agency can
come out and say here's why and explain
what the video was and then people will
understand why it wasn't put up or they
can choose to put the ad up of the old
fat man twerking in front of a little
girl and and then waving to her and they
can say see for yourself why we didn't
want to run it but then they'll have run
it
so i think it's it's an untenable
situation however we got to do it right
so i'm talking to some people we're
looking for uh videos that clearly
depict what it you know what was going
on and we have clearance on copyright
issues for running it as an
advertisement
they'll try and make some arguments like
you know they're clearly going to say
it's not appropriate and like that's
great just make the public statement
that pride parades pride events are not
appropriate for little kids yeah for for
anybody yeah for for ad space because i
mean adults are going to see it is that
is that not okay well of course they
won't allow it that that's the thing
when you have these videos coming out of
these pride events where people are
fully nude and doing these things it is
people turning their faces away and
saying i'm not going anywhere near that
but what happens when someone says i
want to put in a magazine i want that
photo in a magazine i want on the i want
a full page out of the new york times
then they'll all start saying no we
don't accept it it's like when the
parents went to the hearings
over schools and said i'm going to read
from you a passage from a book you
approved for my classroom and then they
shut their mics off like no no you can't
read that stuff in here hypocrisy
i think it was the liberty tick tock
that showed the video of uh
the drag the drag stripper show in
duluth minnesota my my home state where
they had the
the little five and six year olds right
in the front row and they were giving
them dollars to give to the the and then
there's some videos where they put in
their thongs and g-strings yeah all
right normative said bryson gray is
suing spotify for censoring pride month
you can still find it on youtube
hilarious video interesting
i'll check it out
all right
julianne boone says i'm concerned about
ian's posture he should sit up straight
with his shoulders back
thanks jordan peterson
you are right about that that's my
that's my pinned tweet i'll be fixing my
posture this year thanks for reminding
me monkey d
i think it's just holding me back monkey
joe says you have the best content on
youtube
oh we know that's right and that that
also means that sheamus doesn't wait
hold on a second
i mean technically you're right
logically but they're just wrong they're
wrong
fat man says the modern pride flag is a
hidden swastika divided into four parts
i don't know if it was deliberately done
by nazis slowly influencing the take
over the flag's design similar to the
ebay yellow or white situation or if
it's just a happy coincidence
yeah it's funny someone um they got
suspended from twitter for doing that
yep they you if you take the pride flag
you make four of them and you have one
pointing left one pointing up one
pointing right and one pointing down it
makes a swastika that's right that's
funny
scary it's like metaphysical coalescing
spirits yeah strange well there you go
remember when that tariq nasheed guy
made a logo for his company and it was
it was a negative space swastika
so it was like if you take a swastika
and then color in the white portions and
then white out the black portions that's
what he made so it's like everyone's
like bro that's a swastika's like no it
isn't they're like dude it's a swastika
yeah yeah so weird that people do this
man
all right
cited for now excited for now says just
seeing that briar is is retiring
tomorrow instead of later this year not
surprised wonder what they threatened
him with no the it's over the uh aren't
they issuing their last ruling tomorrow
i think they did like an extra day so
they can issue the last ruling and then
the session uh the session is over so
katanji brown jackson will come in and
then the session will start up again
next year i think i don't know
but whatever the
a liberal is being replaced by a far
leftist so i don't think that'll change
a whole lot
and then when trump gets reelected
he's going to replace many more justices
and it's going to be like a
seven to two conservative court or an
eight to one
adam brennaman says maj toure directly
cited along with dred scott in scotus
ruling all gun laws are racist
yes i agree correct
it was it's rooted in racism and uh and
the left they should be coming out and
saying it's racist a lot of drug laws
are rooted in racism too nixon used
those marijuana laws to go after the
black panthers and the hippie movement
and stuff i posted a meme and it's like
this is randy it's a black dude and it's
like randy posts innocent video with him
and his son at the range this is karen
she freaks out and reports it to the
authorities and then it's like a biased
police go to a court and get a a warrant
for the removal of his firearms and then
it shows three cops in armor and it's
like at three a.m armed officers kick in
randy's door his son and wife are
screaming in terror and he's killed
instinctively trying to defend his
family and i'm just like
if you thought stop and frisk was bad
red flag laws are 10 times worse but for
me it's not an issue of race for the
left it is and so the left should be
hearing that and being like oh you're
right instead they're just like nah we
don't care yeah because they're
hypocrites i wanted to say something on
behalf of my shout out to modesto i like
him um
it's they are they it is it is race uh
racism as well but it's really just
anti-freedom and i think a lot of
people's concept of america is flawed in
this way and that we
many of us today believe that the
american government should secure our
freedom it was never intended for the
american government to secure your
freedom you have the rights to secure
your own freedom and in your community
come together and coalesce to to defend
your freedom and and when you
pair the second amendment with uh the
independent business owner a nation of
shopkeepers you get a safeguard against
economic imperialism and tyranny and
that's what america was supposed to be
and many black people need to understand
that going forward so they can vote the
right way all right jedi mind trick says
ian says abortion does not meet the
definition of murder murder is defined
as the unlawful premeditated killing of
a human by another fetuses are not alien
they aren't cats they are human
yeah wait what
i mean it depends on the the
jurisdiction i suppose whether or not
it's a murder
i
i don't think so based on what he's i
don't think that's the point he's making
he's making the point that if murder is
defined as the unlawful premeditated
killing of a human
and fetus is our human and if it's a law
field if it's lawful to kill the fetus
then it's not a murder that's the point
you know the law is homicide murder is
is is it now is it is it is a noun he
just said murder is the illegal killing
of a human if it's murder is defined as
the unlawful premeditated killing of one
human violence unlawful so it's not
unlawful then it's not murder so if it's
not unlawful to kill a human being then
then it's allowed but it's not murder
it's still homicide right
well homicide then use that word okay
all right
armored gesture says ian it took 20 days
to get my son's birth certificate you
need to chill on the weed and look into
these things before you speak in
ignorance yeah whatever first breath
when they're born that's the first thing
i said
so what if we like in order to protect
the baby at like six months or like four
months we stick a snorkel up in there
almost there tim we're very close
they're gonna have neural nets soon the
babies will be leading the way but don't
the babe the babies are breathing when
they're in the womb
i think they're in in liquid i don't
know no they they actually inhale
amniotic fluid to strengthen their lungs
they inhale and exhale cool you can't
have you can't have a heartbeat if
you're not breathing i guess if you're
sucking well they're taking but they're
actually getting oxygen through the
umbilical cord right but they do
exercise their lungs in the uh in the
womb
md says if you think the pride flag is
ridiculous pull up the brooklyn nets
pride flag i honestly thought it was a
troll we all saw that when we brought it
up
i don't know what it is
it's just like every possible flag of
any kind of sexuality mashed into one
weird thing and it's like what is this
called
the brooklyn nets pride flag
pride month is a complete psyop oh well
well maca month is coming up it's time
yes yeah you know maca month wow that
yeah i did see this i got my profile
picture ready you got it so on maga
month everyone changes their profile
pictures to american flags because it's
fourth of july month it's independence
it's it's make america great again a
month yeah it's not about politics it's
about just loving your country and your
neighbors and grilling hot dogs and
burgers and blowing stuff up within the
air fireworks can i can i give an honest
criticism of donald trump real quick of
course absolutely not no
there's no such thing as an honest
criticism of donald trump yeah he's
perfect in every single way i think
one of the one of the shortcomings of
donald trump's
messaging around maga and not no no i'm
not saying this to to be disparaging on
him you know in any
real harsh way but
when i talk to people in my community
and in cd5 in minneapolis they really
believe make america great again is a is
a desire to take america back to a time
when race relations were worse
and it's a huge infowar because in the
1970s there was a moment
where we had racial harmony coming out
of the civil rights movement and the
security state intentionally tried to
subvert
that racial harmony that existed for a
moment but make america great again is
also based largely on foreign policy and
trade
and there was a time in this country
where we had a surplus
and we were the center of manufacturing
and the main message behind make america
great again i think people need to
understand going forward whether you
traditionally identify as republican or
democrat
is that the sovereignty of this country
is being exported to another country
that doesn't believe in human freedom at
all whether you believe in god or not
and that is china and the ccp they don't
believe in human freedom they don't
believe in human rights and they don't
believe in
health care
old people in china don't have health
care so i mean that that's kind of an
info award that i wanted to speak on all
right
leon cintron says the constitution
grants citizenship by birth not by
fertilization the u.s government doesn't
enforce the constitution on non-citizens
until you are born in american territory
or naturalize the us constitution isn't
applicable wrong
you are 100
wrong the supreme court has already
ruled the constitution applies to
non-citizens so long as they are here
that means tourists have free speech
tourists have 2a tourists have a right
to be free from uh search you know
search and seizure and all all of these
um
uh unwarranted
the constitution absolutely applies to
non-citizens
illegal aliens yep they get
constitutional rights that's right they
have free speech they have two-way they
have all of these things
now
with 2a there's probably laws in many
states about permitting about a
non-resident uh
non-resident but not non-citizen
john galt says ian if a u.s woman is a
homesteader and has a baby at home
doesn't get a birth certificate is home
schooled to the age of 18 on the way to
town to get his birth certificate and
the driver
and driver's license he's arrest
arrested is he protected by u.s rights
yeah i think we we already covered it uh
it's birth that gives you the u.s
citizen or the u.s rights but that's why
i asked you like what if they're born in
a in a test tube like what if they're in
an amniotic bag artificial bag
when do their rights on american soil
yeah the moment they're born into the
bag i guess
yeah is that how that's how i imagine
how that's worked it's like when would
you grant them
like when would you recognize their
constitution right it's like an out of
sight out of mind thing i think for a
lot of people because if the baby's
gestating in a glass
case and you can watch it from day one
of fertilization all the way through
you're going to think a lot earlier that
it should deserve those rights i bet
theodore
stetler says here's what it means to be
christian quote that if you confess with
your mouth the lord jesus and believe in
your heart that god has raised him from
the dead you will be saved romans 10 9.
well there you go save from what
eternal damnation
let's grab a couple more
we'll just do a couple more we'll try
and get as many as we can in
wayne martin says to add to royce's
point have we heard any acknowledgments
of the roe v wade ruling from any of the
churches or huge religious leaders
that's a good question i know that um
i've had i've heard people saying that
their their church uh you know their
priest gave a good homily after a row
was overturned i've also heard some
people claiming that their priest or
pastor was condemning the ruling it's a
mixed bag unfortunately
dan and s says given our government's
history on the issue of personhood i
find it disturbing that ian wants to
predicate human value on the
government's definitions
who else is good what else are we going
to predicate it on your feelings
you know these are these are very
difficult moral questions i suppose
but the challenge ultimately is
when does the government have the right
to kill human
whenever they want whenever congress
says it's the time
i mean that's that's the that's the
reality when the government says it they
do it obama's not in prison it's
supposed to be congress that decides it
but the patriot acts insane obama
straight up killed american citizens
with that charge or trial yeah no
accountability federal government is a
frankenstein yeah
all right if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel and share the
show with your friends it's the sharing
that really helps we've actually started
doing some marketing recently we're
going to ramp it up because uh we've
never actually done it until this past
month so that'll be fun over at
timcast.com if you sign up we're gonna
have an exclusive members only show for
you so uh check that out that's gonna be
a lot of fun we'll swear a lot you can
follow the show at timcast irl on
instagram you can follow us on facebook
facebook.comtymcastnews because we're
actually launching a few channels and i
think facebook actually took us out of
the the dog house they they just they
they demonetized me for covering january
6 but they've restored the channel i
guess so we're going to be posting there
again and you can follow me personally
at tim cast basically everywhere royce
you want to shout anything out
royce white dot us is is our
congressional website um also started a
few youtube channels more recently the
last renaissance has won covering my
time in the big three
also just cultural stuff and going on
with me personally and
should be trying to
get a podcast channel coming up here in
the next couple of weeks so stay tuned
for that as well we'll be putting that
content up on the congress website so
right on right on amazing seamus
coughlin
oh man i'm gonna miss you guys gonna
miss all of you this has been great and
i
i love you all if if you haven't got
enough of me yet you can go over to
freedomtunes.com become a member for
five bucks a month you'll get an extra
cartoon
each week you'll also get behind the
scenes content and i'll see you guys
real soon but it's okay we've got uh
another catholic here to replace james
we have american catholic that's right
that's right yep
have a nice evening everyone ian
crossland always great to see you man
and you
i guess the referee was ju was judicious
but we need to go gloves you guys are
supposed to do that like two hour
conversation you've
i mean i've said i i've said before i
don't like i talk about tomorrow one of
those elements of it that i know but i'm
not someone who's when are you qualified
to debate this publicly in my opinion
like i'll get into some arguments about
it if if a point comes up where i know
someone's wrong but when it comes like a
really in-depth dive i really want to do
more reading first just to make sure i'm
not saying like anything irresponsible
or that misses the market speaking which
i've mentioned before you're very like
moralistic as i know like a really
moralistic guy and when tim asked me a
direct question to criticize you i said
drinking like that was like kind of lazy
of me so i would love to go deeper i i
appreciate it and i appreciate that i
mean yeah yeah i'm not on the point too
much but yeah i mean like jesus drank
the apostles drinking so it's not a sin
to have have alcohol also they may have
taken ergot oh i don't agree with that
they also play disco music what that's
that's historically true we're just
making things up with abraham lincoln
i with a straight face have said
historical inaccuracies inaccuracies on
a primetime show because we've already
determined that's a chat movie that's
the way to go that's correct yeah so if
you guys still like making no i'm just
kidding there's no way you can go to
make up stuff like that aoc and tim are
a special class of person thank you very
much for coming by this evening royce
for your big game tomorrow thank you
sheamus for visiting and sharing your
knowledge with us i know you're not a
theologian but i feel like if you have a
firmly held belief that you have a right
and a privilege to share it with people
and to see if you can persuade them to
think the way you think thank you
i do my best i really do do my best i
just i try to be careful if that's like
the specific top i would want to know
like a specific thing you wanted to get
into so that like i could make sure i
was really well read on that specific
part before we dove into it all right
man we'll figure that stuff out uh it'll
be really cool yeah if you uh head over
to timcast.com for the members only show
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all then
you